[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis ravi de vous
retrouver sur public sénat pour vous
faire vivre les travaux des sénateurs le
sénat prépare l'examen du projet de loi
bioéthique qui ouvre la procréation
médicalement assistée à toutes les
femmes
après avoir auditionné le gouvernement
les sénateurs ont entendu ce matin les
associations de familles homoparentales
pour recueillir leur avis sur le projet
de loi et il a notamment été question de
la filiation des couples lesbiens noter
que ces échanges interviennent alors que
la cour de cassation a reconnu hier la
filiation des couples ayant réalisé une
gestation pour autrui à l'étranger
je vous laisse regarder cette audition
je vous remercie de 10 youn et
l'association des familles
homoparentales
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de l'examen de
votre commission spéciale nous vous
aurons nous avons adressé quarante et
une page
quarante et une page en dix minutes on
voit que l'exercice est difficile donc
je vous laisse évidemment vous y référer
et je vais me concentrer je pense sur
avec fabien joly sur deux ou trois
points qui nous semblent très important
et qui ont pu faire l'objet de débats
depuis le vote à l'assemblée nationale
alors comme vous en douter vu le titre
de notre association évidemment nous
sommes extrêmement favorable à
l'ouverture de la procréation
médicalement assistée à toutes les
femmes notamment aux femmes en couple
les femmes de même sexe des femmes à un
couple de même sexe pardon et des femmes
célibataires
je voudrais donc revenir sur cet aspect
particulièrement sur l'établissement de
la filiation parce que c'est un sujet
qui nous est très cher et la modalité
qui a été voté à l'assemblée nationale
en son article 4
nous sommes favorables et nous soutenons
la modalité de reconnaissance conjointe
anticipé qui a été votée par l'assemblée
nationale puisque cette modalité permet
de respecter à la fois je dirais la
solidarité des femmes en couple
lorsqu'elle s'engage dans une pma sont
les deux qui s'engagent dans une pme
évidemment donc il faut qu'elle soit
solidaire au moment où elles veulent
ensemble réalisé ce parcours de
procréation médicalement assistée et
de garantir à 7 et cet épisode
chronologique précis que la filiation
sera ancré à la naissance et sera établi
à la fois par évidemment l'accouchement
de la mère qui va accoucher puisque je
rappelle quand même que c'est elle qui
va transmettre le certificat de
naissance à l'officier d'état civil donc
on aura bien un établissement qui sera à
la fois un établissement qui se devait
de filiation qui sera à la fois reconnu
par l'accouchement de celle qui a couché
et sakho signature avec sa conjointe de
cette fameuse reconnaissance camp de
reconnaissance conjointe anticipées
voilà donc c'est vraiment un système qui
nous semble important de maintenir mais
mais c'est toujours un mais dans la
démonstration il arrive nous
souhaiterions que ce système soit
étendue à tous les enfants qui sont
conçus par pma -avec avec don de gamètes
puisque en l'état on va voir ça comme ça
qu'on pourrait vous le présentez une
rupture d'égalité entre ses enfants qui
serait conçue par par don de gamètes qui
aurait une modalités d'établissement
propre parce que leurs parents sont même
sexe et puis les autres qui sont tous
ceux qui existent déjà depuis plus de 40
ans qui sont ceux qui sont issus de
parents hétérosexuels où on va continuer
d'utiliser le dispositif actuel du du
titre 7 du code civil qui est un
dispositif basé sur le jeu dirait le
rapport charnel ou pseudo charnelle des
parents et qui va proposer un état civil
ou finalement aucune information
permettra à l'intéressé de savoir qu en
réalité son père on va parler du don de
sperme ou majorité n'est pas le géniteur
la question qui vous est posée
aujourd'hui
finalement elle a déjà été posée il ya
bien longtemps
parce que en 1950 on pas à parler
pendant une ou deux minutes de
l'adoption en 1956 à une circulaire à
l'état civil qui était mise
keegan demandé aux officiers d'état
civil de ne pas envoyer la mention du
jugement de l'adoption des enfants qui
ont été adoptées
en d'autres termes on va donc leur faire
croire
y compris à la famille si elle n'a rien
dit à l'enfant adopté que cet enfant est
issu de ses parents et que ses parents
sont ses géniteurs puisque l'état civil
sera exactement dressé de la même
manière et donc pendant toutes ces
années on conserve cette circulaire est
en 1966 on se réveille et on se dit mais
non mais qu'est ce qu'on a fait
finalement
pendant des années on a voulu faire
croire que les enfants adoptés avait
comme parent et géniteur ceux qui ont
été confirmés dans le jugement
d'adoption mais on s'est trompés parce
que aujourd'hui ces enfants sont devenus
grands ils parlent ils disent mais nous
on n'a aucune aucun problème avec avec
cette information et on veut aussi cette
transparence et on veut savoir que nos
parents biologiques puisque dans lequel
l'adoption il s'agit évidemment de
rupture avec la famille biologique vers
une famille qui va adopter qui n'a aucun
lien biologique avec ses enfants et est
donc cette mutation à l'interné en 1966
et elle vient dire à l'officier d'état
civil
arrêtez d'envoyer des extraits il n'y
avait pas la mention de ces jugements
d'adoption en vous faisant croire que
c'était un acte intégral et envoyé
l'intégrale maintenant envoyer l'acte
intégrale avec toutes la mention parce
que oui nous et à nous devons la vérité
à ses enfants et nous ne devons pas
continuer une perpétuation du mensonge
sur l'établissement de cette filiation
est le problème que vous avez
aujourd'hui mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs en fait il est
parfaitement transposable sur ses
enfants conçus par don de gamètes c'est
à dire qu'on est en train de vous dire
attention l'intérêt supérieur de ses
enfants à disposer d'une garantie de
connaissance de leur histoire
personnelle est supérieur à l'intérêt
supérieur de leur parent de disposer un
acte qui serait conforme à
l'établissement d'une filiation
charnelle ou pseudo charnel en d'autres
termes ce qu'on vient vous demander de
faire aujourd'hui c'est d'étendre le
dispositif qui est uniquement réservée
aux femmes lesbiennes dans l'article 4 à
tous les enfants nés de dons parce que
nous affirmons qu'un nouveau qu'un
enfant a autant le droit de disposer de
la garantie d'accès de son histoire
personnelle que ses parents soient
hétérosexuels ou homosexuels mariés ou
non
c'est donc l'égalité des droits de ces
enfants qui doit primer sur toute autre
considération
c'est d'ailleurs le sens de toutes les
conventions internationales peut-être
que vous les connaissez c'est aussi le
sens qu'ils ont pris de nombreux arrêts
de la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme voilà le premier point qui même
qui me semblait important
j'aurais juste passer la parole à fabien
joly sur la possession d'état peut-être
et l'accès aux origines pour les enfants
déjà nés
monsieur je vous rappelle dix minutes
par intervenant si possible oui j'y
reste coi deux trois minutes non oui
c'est ça je n'irais pas plus je n'irai
pas au delà monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
effectivement l'association que nous
représentons défend la rca et son
extension à tous les enfants quelle que
ce qu'ils soient issus et bien d'un don
dans le cas d'une famille hétérosexuelle
ou homosexuelle
ce projet de loi tel qu'il a été adopté
à l'assemblée nationale en première
lecture au delà effectivement de limiter
la rca aux seuls couples de femmes
eh bien on envisage pas ou n'envisage
que mal deux autres problématiques nous
semble aujourd'hui essentielle toujours
au nom de l'intérêt supérieur des
enfants nés dans le cadre d'une
assistance à la procréation
ce sont d'abord tous les enfants qui
sont nés et qui seront menées avant
l'entrée de cette loi et notamment la
question de l'établissement de la
filiation de ses enfants qui seront nés
dans le quatre de couple de femmes avant
l'entrée en vigueur de cette loi
aujourd'hui la seule mécanique qui leur
est possible et qu'il aurait réservé
c'est la voie de l'adoption même si
effectivement le gouvernement parle
demain de modifier les conditions
légales de l'adoption en supprimant
notamment la condition maritale preat
préalable il n'en restera pas moins que
un certain nombre d'enfants
ne pourront pas être adopté pour la
simple et bonne raison que les deux
maires qu'ils l'ont élevé aussi bien
celle qui en accouche et que la mère
sociale ne sont plus ensemble et que
même si on supprime la condition
maritale est bien la mère qui en a
accouché et qui pour l'instant la seule
reconnue ne consentira peut-être pas
c'est malheureusement des cas très
nombreux dans lesquels il y à un conflit
entre ces deux femmes et un homme s'est
tué ma mère telle qu'elle est reconnue
par aujourd'hui comme étant la seule
seul parent en droit français ne
consentiront pas à l'adoption de son
enfant vis-à-vis de la mère sociale et
aujourd'hui nous n'avons aucun moyen
juridique de faire établir cette
filiation à l'égard de cette mère
sociale alors même que celle ci aurait
voulu cet enfant aurait participé au
projet parental et aurait élevé pendant
de nombreuses années
cet enfant voilà pourquoi nous soutenons
nous pour tenter de trouver une solution
juridique à ces situations qui sont
généralement dramatique tant pour les
mères que pour les enfants et bien nous
soutenons la possibilité que cette
filiation soit établie par la voix de la
possession d'état ce qui permettrait
effectivement à la mère sociale jusqu'à
dix ans après la séparation d'avec là
mère juridique est bien de pouvoir par
un ensemble d'éléments qu'elle pourrait
rapporter devant notaire ou le cas
échéant devant le tribunal de grande
instance qui deviendra dans quelques
jours le tribunal judiciaire
eh bien elle pourrait voir établi sa
filiation et donc maintenir les liens
qu'elle a toujours eu ou qu'elle a
toujours voulu avoir
avec cet enfant et ça cela nous semble
vraiment un élément manquant du projet
loi tel qu'il a été présenté est tel
qu'il a été adopté à l'assemblée
nationale pas de solution pour ces
enfants enfin je vais terminer très
rapidement sur la commission d'accès aux
origines
il nous semble là et je parle à nouveau
des enfants qui sont nés dmp avant la
loi il nous semble tout à fait
impensable que ces enfants là ne puisse
pas et bien bénéficié avec l'accord
évidemment du donneur mais d'un
c'est à des données non identifiantes ou
à l'identité du donneur puisque le
nouveau système réserve cette faculté la
aux seuls enfants qui seront menées dans
le cadre de la nouvelle loi donc d'ici
18 ou 20 ans mais tous les enfants qui
sont nés auparavant il n'y a aucune
raison
si le donneur on est d'accord bien
évidemment et bien qu'il ne puisse pas
avoir accès à cette information
et c'est pourquoi on sollicite non pas
le volontariat des donneurs parce qu'on
sait très bien que ceci est un peu une
vue de l'esprit mais que la commission
d'accès aux origines et la possibilité
de solliciter les donneurs pour savoir
s'il consentirait ou pas à ce que leurs
données identifiantes soient communiqués
à des enfants issus d'un don si ceux ci
en font la demande et ça nous paraît
être aussi là un bonne une un bon
système d' équilibre une solution d'
équilibre entre le respect de l'anonymat
qu'ils avaient été garantis à l'époque
puisqu'on le lèvera que si le donneur en
est d'accord
et puis la situation des enfants qui ont
aujourd'hui un droit à connaître leur
histoire personnelle
voilà les quelques mots monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs les
stater que je souhaitais ajouté après
ceux du président de l'association merci
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs ghalib et un mouvement lgbt
associés aux radicaux une association à
caractère politique donc mon propos le
sera également mon parti au delà du
texte avec la pgl et le planning
familial et d'autres associations et
avec le soutien des sauver son
homophobie ou encore de l'inter lgbt
nous avons cet été créé un collectif
collectif pma aussi certains éléments
seront développées notamment par la pgl
vous nous auditionné aujourd'hui sur le
projet de loi bioéthique ouvrant la pma
à toutes les femmes
ce texte nous l'attendons depuis
longtemps depuis très longtemps
peut-être même trop longtemps nous
l'attendions de la précédente majorité
mandature promesses du candidat hollande
non réalisés ce qui est un vraiment
peut-être d'ailleurs cela aurait-il nous
aurait été d'éviter d'avoir à nous
marier et adopter notre propre par an
pour être connu nos propres enfants
pardon pour être reconnu pleinement
comme parents s'ils ont plus tard
l'heure n'est plus à faire des comptes
et refaire le match de ce qui n'a pas
été fait ou fait et par qui mais plutôt
de constater que ce texte est une
avancée mais qui ne n'est pas parfait
j'y reviendrai tout à l'heure que tout
n'a pas été fait que tout n'a pas été
prévu et que surtout le moment venu dans
l'hémicycle nous aurons besoin de tous
les progressistes
quelles que soient leurs opinions leur
bord politique opposition comprise donc
de gauche de droite centristes
indépendants et même radicaux le sénat
est majoritairement à droite jeu
peut-être vous inviter à une par
commettre certaines erreurs du passé
après les oppositions au pacs en mariage
et à l'adoption souvent plus par posture
que par conviction peut-être même
parfois par peur de ce que pourraient
penser votre électorat en
circonscription
je veux vous rappeler que sur la pma
comme sur le mariage sondage après
sondage les français sont prêts et
depuis bien longtemps et comme souvent
bien avant de législateurs nos familles
nos conjoints nos enfants sont une
réalité
intégré à la société et à travers toute
la france le schéma familial est
aujourd'hui et divers multiples à la
fois traditionnels les familles
recomposées monoparentales mais aussi
homoparentales aujourd'hui nous nous
réjouissons de voir la pma pour les
femmes seules et en couple enfin à
l'agenda parlementaire de voir ce droit
de voir cette liberté nouvelle ouverte à
toutes les femmes
la liberté de pouvoir faire un enfant la
liberté de pouvoir disposer de son corps
pour concevoir un enfant
la liberté de pouvoir faire famille quel
que soit son régime matrimonial ou son
orientation sexuelle
j'en suis persuadé cela restera dans
l'histoire comme une grande avancée pour
les femmes comme les droits de vote
ou comme le droit à l'avortement je veux
souligner les points positifs
l'aspect historique est attendue de ce
texte bien sûr mais aussi l'ouverture de
la pma aux femmes célibataires qui est
un marqueur important de confiance faite
aux femmes dans un projet parental
mûrement réfléchie cependant nous ne
pouvons pas accepter de voir ce projet
de loi que dans ce projet de loi des
dispositions de filiation dédié
spécifique pour les couples de femmes
soit prévu qu'il n'est la filiation
naturelle de la femme qui accouche
nous ne pouvons pas comprendre que les
lois de la république s'organisent pour
mettre en place un statut à part pour
une catégorie de la population pour les
couples de femmes comme femme comme
lesbienne comme élu moi même je ne peux
pas me résoudre à ce que la république
ne protège pas de la même manière tous
ses enfants
on ne peut pas défendre les personnes
lgbt
nos familles nos enfants et soutenir une
dispositions discriminantes à leur
endroit
nous souhaitons que le droit commun soit
élargie soit par reconnaissance soit par
présomption
autre manque de ce texte les personnes
trans écarté de l'accès à la pma elles
doivent y être intégré le refus de la
pma post mortem également cela marque
une forme d'incohérence une femme ne
pourrait pas acheter un projet parental
avec les gamètes de son défunt conjoint
mais par contre pourrait avoir accès à
la pma avec un tiers donneur en tant que
femme célibataire manque aussi la
promesse de campagne de reconnaître les
enfants nés de gp a réalisé légalement à
l'étranger
je le répète nos enfants doivent être
protégés par la république comme tous
les autres enfants
vous l'avez compris ce texte est
l'opportunité de mettre en exergue la
valeur famille sous les triptyques de la
république l'égalité égalité fraternité
liberté égalité fraternité liberté de
développer l'égalité l'égalité enfin
réel et la fraternité sans laquelle les
deux autres ne serait rien et
j'ajouterai le quatrième budget de la
république la laïcité qui vous le savez
nous nous est cher à nous radicaux je le
sais des représentants des cultes ont
été auditionnés à l'assemblée et même
ici du roi
n'oublions pas que depuis plus d'un
siècle le religieux ne doit pas
influencer le législateur enfin pour
conclure deux éléments tout d'abord que
ce texte va dans le sens de l'histoire
comme pour le mariage par le passé nous
parlons ici d'élargir quelque chose qui
est déjà partiellement autorisée légal
ouvert aux couples hétérosexuels tous
les coupes ne souhaite pas se marier
de la même manière toutes les femmes ne
souhaitent pas avoir des enfants
donc il en est de même pour la pma
mais nous parlons ici de la liberté de
la liberté de pouvoir faire la liberté
par choix et non pas par contrainte de
l'interdiction et enfin vous dire que
j'ai toujours considéré que le rôle du
politique n'était pas de juger la
société mais de savoir l'observer pour
mieux l'accompagner
je vous remercie monsieur le président
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs
d'abord je tenais à vous remercier pour
votre activité à sion à cette table
ronde de notre association sos
homophobie association qui lutte depuis
25 ans contre les discriminations envers
les personnes lgbt
avec trois axes le soutien aux victimes
la sensibilisation aux discriminations
notamment en milieu scolaire et la
militance pour l'égalité des droits des
personnes lgbt
alors je vais utiliser ici mon temps de
parole introductif pour tenter de donner
un éclairage donc j'espère
complémentaire aux débats qui nous
portent principalement sur des terrains
juridique de construction de la loi de
techniques médicales ou même ici de
bioéthique alors un premier propos sur
le véhicule législatif qui nous est
imposée pour parler de nos vies de nos
familles et d'égalité en droits
notre embarras même parfois attend voir
se focaliser l'attention et le temps des
parlementaires des médias et du public
sur les quelques articles qui nous
concerne plutôt que sur la trentaine
d'autres articles autrement plus
engageante sur l'avenir et sur les
questions de bioéthique justement mais
dont acte et je vais donc pour ma part
me concentrer sur les deux articles
principaux sur lesquels notre
association porte voix à savoir les
articles 1 ayant pour objet d'élargir
l'accès à de nouveaux publics et
l'article 4 qui en tire les conséquences
en termes de filiation sur l'article 1
donc je tiens à exprimer et je rejoins
catherine notre satisfaction de voir
enfin une discrimination basée sur
l'orientation sexuelle et le statut
marital des femmes tombées nous
l'attendions depuis 25 ans 25 ans oui
car il ne s'agit ici ni de développer
une nouvelle technique ni de créer de
nouvelles situations mais bien de faire
de mettre fin à une inégalité de
traitement entre les personnes dans
notre pays
basée sur l'orientation sexuelle
le statut marital et il s'agit
évidemment de protéger les enfants et
les familles ayant eu recours à la mp je
précise que cette inégalité a été créée
ex nihilo par le législateur en 1994 qui
a fait le choix que d'autres pays n'ont
pas fait d'inclure fives et y a des dans
une loi globale de bioéthique et d'en
réserver l'accès aux seuls couples
hétérosexuels
ceci exclut de facto les femmes seules
et en couple avec une femme qui jusque
là pouvaient être accompagnés par leurs
médecins et gynécologues dans un cadre
médical sécurisé je parle ici
principalement d y a des cependant notre
satisfaction n'est pas totale car une
partie nos concitoyens sont à nouveau
discriminés par les choix actuels les
hommes trans qui serait en capacité de
porter un enfant sont en effet exclu de
l'article 1er en nous considérons que
les droits reproductifs appartiennent à
la personne et que le sexe établi à
l'état civil ne doit pas être une source
d' empêchement à la mp la loi qui depuis
2016 permet un changement d'état civil
sans stérilisation forcée obligerait à
présent les hommes trans à choisir entre
leur changement d'état civil et la
possibilité de porter un enfant en
regard des débats et des propos tenus au
cours des travaux à l'assemblée
nationale je ne vous cache pas que nous
avons malheureusement peu d'illusions
sur le succès de voir notre demande
d'inclusivité de toute personne en
capacité de porter un enfant un plus à
l'article 1er
depuis 1994 donc des milliers de femmes
en france ont été empêchés par la loi de
bénéficier de l'accompagnement de leur
médecin parce que célibataire ou parce
que lesbienne
conséquence elles ont été obligées de se
tourner exclusivement vers des
stratégies de contournement à savoir les
pme artisanales et les pma à l'étranger
je rappelle en quelques mots les
conséquences très concrètes de cet état
de fait qui aura duré 25 ans
insécurité et violence sanitaires liés à
la provenance du sperme aux aléas de
stérilisation au traitement lourd et
inutile imposé par les cliniques
étrangères les inégalités sociales et
économiques liées au coût de la mp des
déplacements des nuitées sur place des
absences au travail à la possibilité
même de ces absences
et enfin une précarité juridique de la
famille une fois l'enfant né pour dans
un couple de femmes
alors les premières victimes de ces
inégalités sont bien évidemment de ces
violences sont bien évidemment les
femmes puis leur enfant leur femme et
leurs compagnes et enfin le reste de la
famille les oncles les tantes les
grands-parents qui jusqu'à
l'établissement de la double filiation
plusieurs mois après la naissance de
l'enfant dans le meilleur des cas et
uniquement pour les couples mariés n'ont
aucune existence légale envers l'enfant
nous parlons là des droits comme des
devoirs
d'où l'importance à nos yeux de cet
article 1er et de son ouverture à de
nouveaux publics
j'en profite ici pour mentionner la
corrélation connu étayé notamment par le
rapport annuel sur l'homophobie en
france publié par notre association
entre les discriminations dans la loi
les comportements discriminatoires
toléré dans la société jusqu'aux
violences physiques et psychologiques
qui touche les personnes lgbt plus un
chiffre un seul ici en 2018 les
violences lesbophobes signalés à sos au
et à sos homophobie pardon ont augmenté
de 42 % en un an ce sont 360 5 actes
signalé et j'insiste ce qu'ils ont été
signalés uniquement soit un acte
lesbophobes par jour en 2018 je rebondis
donc ici à nouveau sur l'importance à
nos yeux de faire évoluer la loi pour
que personne ne soit discriminé et je
mentionne donc à nouveau les personnes
trans et en profite également pour
porter attention sur la situation des
personnes intersexe dans notre pays
alors j'en viens maintenant au second
article article 4 de la loi qui nous
occupe ici comme l'ensemble des
associations portant un plaidoyer sur la
pme ayant un objectif de donner un cadre
légal et égalitaire à toute personne et
tout couple ayant recours à la mp avec
tiers donneur
nous ne nous satisfaisons pas de
l'option proposée par le gouvernement
est retenue par les députés qui consiste
en l'établissement d'une filiation
spécifique pour les couples de femmes à
savoir la reconnaissance conjointe
anticipées
je sais que vous avez auditionné des
jurys je me garderai donc bien de
discuter les détails techniques mais je
clarifie tout de même nous sommes en
faveur de l'extension du droit commun
pour rester dans la vie concrète les
raisons notre insatisfaction au droit
dérogatoire sont très simples cette loi
pour ambition de mettre fin à une
discrimination envers certaines
personnes et notamment les femmes
lesbiennes
or créer un droit dérogatoire à leur
encontre c'est créer une nouvelle
discrimination
c'est donc prendre du main ce que l'on
donne de l'autre
cette loi doit créer également la
protection de tous les enfants et de
toutes les familles sans discrimination
sans hiérarchisation sans création de
documents ad-hoc pour certains enfants
en raison de leur mode de conception ou
en raison de l'orientation sexuelle de
leurs parents ce choix d'un droit
dérogatoire nous semble d'autant plus
incompréhensible que tout existe déjà
dans le droit
c'est le système de filiation imaginez
en 1994 pour les couples hétérosexuels
ayant recours à une pma avec donneur qui
n'a jamais été mise en défaut depuis je
ne reviendrai pas encore une fois sur la
technicité de ce droit d'autres l'ont
fait avant moi quand je dis que tout
existe je précise tout de même la mp
avec tiers donneur existe la double
filiation maternelle existe la filiation
d'un enfant avec un parent nos géniteurs
existe très concrètement ce que le texte
actuel c'est-à-dire la rca
reconnaissance conjoint anticipe
implique pour les femmes c'est que
l'établissement de sa filiation avec son
enfant sera différente pour la femme qui
accouche selon qu'elle est en couple
avec un homme ou avec une femme
différents pour le second parent non
géniteur dans les deux cas selon qu'il
est un homme ou qu'il est une femme de
plus l'acte de naissance d'un enfant
sera différent selon que ses parents ont
eu recours avec à une pma avec donneur
ou pas et selon l'orientation sexuelle
de ses parents ce que nous attendons de
la loi est donc très simple c'est quand
même conception
il y est même filiation la femme qui
accouche doit être mère par son
accouchement
le second parent doit l'être par
consentement au don plus présomption si
marié consentement au don plus
reconnaissance sinon marié
comme c'est déjà le cas dans le droit
actuel pour les couples hétérosexuels
que le second parent soit homme ou femme
ne devrait rien changer
sauf à considérer que les couples
pourtant passé dans une même situation
au regard de la conception ne se valent
pas et là il faudrait alors assumer un
nouveau disque roi d'inscrire dans la
loi une discrimination basée sur
l'orientation sexuelle des personnes
le blocage à cette évidence de
l'extension du droit commun qui a tous
les mérites y compris celui de la
simplicité et de ne rien enlever à
personne ni aux femmes célibataires ni
aux couples hétérosexuels
il faut le chercher selon nous du côté
du paradigme des terreaux normativité de
notre droit qui a de plus été fait par
et pour les hommes
l'actualité est la difficulté d'imposer
une véritable égalité entre femmes et
hommes sur nombre d'autres sujets nous
le rappelle de manière très vive et
douloureuse à nous les femmes
la difficulté de beaucoup à penser la
famille en dehors du couple hétérosexuel
et d'envisager la diversité de nos
personnes et de notre société renforcer
ici par quelques siècles de pratique du
droit de la famille fondée sur le
mariage réservée aux couples composés
d'un homme et d'une femme jusqu'en 2013
et la volonté de contrôler le corps des
femmes et de la procréation
le mariage du pour tous ne seraient donc
toujours pas un mariage pour toutes car
le mariage entre deux femmes n'en
porterai toujours pas les mêmes effets
en termes de filiation que le mariage
entre un homme et une femme
pourtant placé de la même
pourtant placé pardon de lune de façon
similaire face à une amp avec donneur
l'histoire l'anthropologie des sciences
sociales n'ont pourtant de cesse de nous
montrer que les systèmes de parenté et
donc de filiation sont et ont toujours
été soumis à des normes culturelles
changeantes et aux évolutions politiques
économiques sociales religieuses mêmes
donc bio technique alors reconnaissance
anticipée non reconnaissance non car
rupture d'égalité de droits en droit des
effets du mariage conjointe n'ont qu'à
rupture d'égalité entre les femmes qui
accouchent
anticipées n'ont qu'à rupture d'égalité
d'établissement filiation entre des
enfants selon que leur mère est en
couple avec une femme ou pas il n'y a
pas de modèle universel de la famille
encore moins de modèles uniques
il y a par contre selon nous un seul
type d'égalité il n'y a pas d'égalité
partiel
l'égalité est où elle n'est pas je
m'arrête là pour rester dans les limites
de temps merci beaucoup
en effet c'est important que vous soyez
dans les limites de temps pour laisser
du temps à nos collègues rapporteur est
ainsi qu'à nos collègues sénatrices et
sénateurs de pouvoir vous poser des
questions
donc vous pourrez éventuellement
reprendre de développer à ce moment là
je remercie madame lorraine chainel de
prendre le relais bonjour bonjour madame
à la vice-présidente mesdames messieurs
les rapporteurs mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs dont je suis la déléguée
famine l'intérêt de gbt je suis aussi
maman de deux petites filles nées par
pma à l'hôpital universitaire de bruce
devint conçu à l'hôpital universitaire
de bruxelles mais en france l'inter lgbt
rassemble 70 associations dans tous les
domaines de la vie lgbt ou un peu plus
largement des droits humains nous
organisons chaque année la marche des
fiertés de paris
le printemps des associations et nous
faisons régulièrement du plaidoyer
je voudrais juste commencé par un regret
c'est que l'association des enfants
d'arc en ciel qui accompagne chaque
année des dizaines voire des centaines
de femmes dans des ipm à des couples de
femmes en bm n'a pas autorisé et n'a pas
été autorisé à être auditionné alors je
pense que ça aurait été assez
enrichissant
alors dans la loi déjà énormément de
points positifs
l'ouverture de la mp aux couples de
femmes qui met fin à une situation
cynique où nos familles étaient un peu
bancal mmm est reconnue en droit quand
même et obliger à aller fonder sur le
modèle du ni vu ni connu à l'étranger
qui était une source d'inégalité
financière puisque c'était donc ça
coûtait ça peut coûter relativement cher
c'est entre eux
mille euros pour une insémination et 5,6
8000 euros pour une fiv par tentatives
c'est une source de stress d'aller à
l'étranger c'est des sources de
problèmes de santé puisque le le lien
entre les médecins français et étrangers
parfois difficiles à faire et c'est
source de difficultés dans le travail
parce que du coup ça oblige à des
absences difficile à justifier alors que
quand on est suivi à l'hôpital français
on a des justificatifs
nous sommes très satisfaits qui est une
clause de dink le nom de
non-discrimination incluse à l'assemblée
nationale voilà il nous voulons rappeler
bien sûr que les travaux de suzanne
colombo reprenant l'ensemble des études
portant sur le bien-être des enfants nés
dans les couples de femmes et les femmes
célibataires montre que nos enfants
devront tout aussi bien que les autres
nous sommes aussi très satisfait qu'il
ait l'ouverture aux femmes célibataires
pour nous il est important de bien
comprendre que une femme célibataire qui
a un réel projet parental et qui se
tournent vers une amp est dans une
situation très différente des femmes qui
ont décidé de faire un enfant à deux et
qui se retrouvent à les lever tout seuls
c'est là un accident de la vie alors que
dans le premier cas on a prévu les
conséquences
c'est quelque chose qui s'est donc un
profil aussi socio économiques très
différents les études le monde et en
plus ceux ci pourra être vérifiée par
les équipes et les équipes de mp ce sont
des familles qui sont entourés et qui
sont soutenues très largement et qui
d'ailleurs parfois aussi ils rencontrent
des pères après parce que ne sont pas
condamnés célibataire toute la vie voilà
c'est quelque chose d'important pour
nous parce que
le la fenêtre pour fonder une famille
actuellement et trèves et très fermé
pour les femmes
on attend en général un cdi le premier
cdi c'est pas avant 29 ans et à partir
de 35 38 ans votre fertilité baisse donc
l'âge pour avoir le prince sur la
princesse charmante est assez limité et
donc malheureusement un certain nombre
de personnes qui ont envie de porter un
enfant et bien se décide à le faire a
commencé en tout cas à le faire et à
l'élever seule
voilà pour ne pas avoir annoncé le
remboursement est très important puisque
c'est non seulement le principe de
solidarité de notre système de santé
mais surtout si non en fait compte tenu
du prix on remettra exactement les mêmes
discriminations que celle qu'on a
actuellement pour les femmes forcées
d'aller à l'étranger
d'autres progrès le double don qui
permettra d'éviter surtout
majoritairement à des couples
hétérosexuels mais de s'en aller à
l'étranger chaque année et l'accès aux
arts et aux origines qui était très
attendu des enfants en tout cas de
certains enfants de l'étude ont
maintenant des manques
alors je vais pas reprendre ce qui a été
dit précédemment par par catherine
michaud sur la question des veuves
mais en effet la situation est assez
cruel dans le projet doit leur propose
d'autoriser mais seulement avec un
donneur et pas avec les conjoints ou les
embryons conçus avec leur leur conjoint
la question des personnes trans et
intersexe s'est très bien défendu et
expliqué par véronique girard ajouterait
aussi le fait que actuellement ces
personnes n'ont pas accès à l'auto
conservation des gamètes quand bien même
elles subissent un traitement c'est un
traitement stérilisant ce qui est
absolument discriminatoire puisque
normalement en vertu de la loi actuelle
elle devrait pouvoir y avoir et avoir
recours d'autant que maintenant elles
pourront a priori utiliser les gamètes
il y à un certain nombre de techniques
médicales et de pratiques qui pour nous
manque la question de la rampe à qui
pour nous a été alors la repasser donc
la possibilité de donner ses ovocytes à
sa conjointe à l'assemblée nationale il
ya une confusion en fait on a
l'impression que c'était un don mais ce
n'est pas un don parce que là la
génitrice deviendra bien mère à la
naissance de l'enfant
ce n'est qu'il l'utilisation des gamètes
du cou et dans un contexte de pénurie
d'ovocytes
c'est ridicule de faire attendre à
quelqu'un alors qu'à des gammes est
disponible dans le couple de la mettre
sur une liste d'attenté de plus de trois
ans pour obtenir des ovocytes la
question du dépistage des anneaux dit
alors c'est un dépistage en fait c'est
pas un nouveau dépistage ce dépistage il
est proposé à chaque femme aux trois
mois de grossesse
ce qu'on propose depuis 2009 et la femme
peut l'accepter ou le refuser c'est qu'
on puisse proposer aux femmes de faire
ce dépistage avant en fait dès des
l'embryon en cas de fil puisque 40% des
fiv donne lieu à des échecs notamment à
cause d'un embryon qu'ils sont non
viables en fait
ou alors qui de toutes manières
donnerait possibilité après de faire une
interruption médicale de grossesse donc
c est pour les femmes qu'ils ne
souhaiteraient pas le faire elles ne
font pas voilà donc c'est s'est pas
vraiment unsa a été présenté comme une
grande nouveauté mais en fait ça ne
l'est pas mais par contre ça sera
beaucoup plus confortable pour les
femmes parce que être obligé est un
faire des fausses couches
c'est vraiment pas agréable et être
obligé de faire une interruption
médicale de grossesse à trois mois quand
vous êtes en processus de paix m
c'est vraiment extrêmement difficile il
ya aussi la question de la
simplification des appariements pour les
donneurs et donneuses rares bons la
plupart des de nombreux habitants
français sont plutôt de type caucasien
caucasiens mais il existe aussi des gens
de toutes différences techniques et
évidemment comme ils sont moins nombreux
dans la population française ils sont
moins nombreux chez les donneurs et chez
les donneuses donc comment créer un
registre national nous souhaiterions que
ce registre national soient consultables
par les médecins qui pratiquent les amp
pour éventuellement pouvoir orienter ou
faire venir des gamètes qui serait
disponible dans d'autres centres parce
qu'actuellement chaque centre fonctionne
qu'avec ses propres g ses propres gammes
est sans communiquer avec les autres et
offrir la possibilité aux couples qui le
souhaitent de refuser tout à paris n'en
basé sur leurs caractéristiques
physiques parce qu'actuellement il ya
des couples à qui on refuse l'accès à
une amp parce qu'on n'a pas par exemple
le couple à une personne noire et qu'on
n'a pas de donneur ou de donneuses noir
spécialement de donneuses d'ovocytes
noire il y en a deux pour toute la
france alors que si ça se trouve alors
qu'un certain nombre de couples ça ne
les dérangerait pas d'avoir un enfant
qui donc la possibilité de refuser ça
sur la filiation je pense que véronique
on a très bien parlé nous sommes en
faveur d'une filiation de droit commun
identique à celle des couples
hétérosexuels non mariés pour nous juste
sur la la reconnaissance avec la
possibilité de déclarer judiciairement
la parentalité
si jamais ce n'est pas fait par la
seconde maman actuellement si ce n'est
pas fait par le papa c'est je voudrais
souligner au delà des caractères
discriminatoires qui a été donné le fait
qu'il n'ait pas vraiment de d'obstacles
en droit c'est une solution très simple
qui a fait ses preuves donc depuis 1994
et on n'a pas besoin de revoir le
contentieux puisque il suffirait en fait
d'apporter comme preuve le consentement
devant notaire à l'officier d'état civil
il y à la situation dramatique des
couples séparés avant l'adoption de
l'enfant du conjoint de 9h a très bien
parlé qui sont actuellement sans aucune
possibilité d'établissement de la
filiation
donc ils ont parlé de la possibilité
d'ouverture de la possession d'état qui
serait aussi notre voie favorite
il existe une autre voie qu'est la voix
belge qui a ouvert l'adoption de
l'enfant de l'ex conjoint alors
ex-conjoint ex-partenaire ex-concubin si
on veut
couvrir toutes les situations en
permettant si la femme qui a l'autorité
parentale le refuse un recours à un juge
c'est le juge qui tranchera ce qui nous
paraît assez assez équilibré puisque le
juge noah paraît le meilleur garant de
l'intérêt de l'enfant
sur les quatre jp à l'étranger je
rappelle que l'inter lgbt n'a pas de
position à ge n'a pas de position sur la
question sauf sur la régularisation de
l'état civil des enfants il ya eu hier
une description très intéressant
jugement de la cour de cassation qui
fait évoluer sa jurisprudence et permet
la transcription des deux parents donc
ça se respire de rance pourrait être
entérinée par la loi et enfin le cas des
personnes trans dont on a déjà parlé
enfin nous avons quelques sujets hors du
des questions pma je vais aller très
vite la question du traitement
algorithmique des données sans le
consentement des personnes ce qui
concerne l'article 11 et d'un dispositif
concret d'alert la question du statut de
l'embryon à l'article 14 qui nous posent
quelques soucis des questions liées à la
nouvelle clause de conscience dans
l'article 21 sur les mg au lieu de
renvoyer à la clause de conscience déjà
existantes sur les vg et la question des
mineurs intersexe où il y a eu une
avancée notable à l'assemblée nationale
mais où nous souhaiterions que pour que
la france soit soit conforme aux
recommandations et d'ailleurs aux
engagements laquelle elle a pu prendre
part par la voix de de certains de
d'interdire les multiples les les
opérations non consentie par les enfants
voilà juste pour finir donc une jeune
femme des enfants d'arc en ciel qui est
né par de pma mais en dix neuf ans en
1995 qui nous dit elle souffert de la
situation de mes parents dans ma vie non
j'ai une certitude que tout le monde n'a
pas la chance d'avoir je sais que mes
parents m'ont ardemment désirée et que
j'existe parce qu'elles se sont battus
pour ça
cela donnait un premier sens à ma vie je
n'ai pas souffert de l'homosexualité de
mes parents j'ai souffert de
l'homophobie de notre société
la seconde question qu'on me pose et je
manquais d'un père la réponse est encore
non j'ai eu l'amour de deux femmes j'ai
eu des hommes dans mon entourage
mon parrain mon grand père mes oncles
les pères de mes amis mais qu'est ce
qu'un père apporte de 6 spécifique
qu'une mère ne peut apporter
l'autorité le goût pour le sport l'idée
selon laquelle le père est indispensable
sous-entend que l'homme est
fondamentalement différent de la femme
au point qu'il apporterait par sa seule
masculinité quelque chose de distinct
mon expérience démontre que cette idée
est fausse je vous demande mesdames et
messieurs de pau les sénateurs de voter
cet article du projet de loi
vivre dans un état qui ne reconnaît pas
ma famille est une souffrance voire des
jeunes homosexuels de mon âge beauté de
leur capacité à être de bonne mère à
cause de l'homophobie ambiante est
insupportable notre ami existe déjà par
milliers
merci merci je voulais préciser que pour
l'association arc en ciel en définitive
nous leur avons demandé de se rapprocher
de votre fédération parce que finalement
ils sont intégrés dans votre fédération
et donc on ne peut pas dire que les
enfants d'arc en ciel n'ont pas été
autorisés à en tout cas exprimé
aujourd'hui leur avis à travers vous
bonjour c'est le cas de la dh
bon en tout cas c'est une précision que
je voulais apporter
monsieur dominique boraine on accueille
aussi madame picarda qui est arrivé
entre temps bien merci mesdames et
messieurs de nous accueillir et de nos
x2 est de nouveau auditionné aujourd'hui
au-delà du fait qu effectivement enfin
arc-en-ciel est membre de la fédération
intérêts de gbt c'est aussi un plaisir
de travailler avec elle
lorsque nous sommes auditionner tous
ensemble ce sont des voix importantes
entendre indépendamment des fédérations
mais je comprends à lormont proposera
dans de temps si vous voulez bien le
premier vous rappeler qui est la pj end
où nous venons et un peu l'expérience de
la bgl qui a été qu'ils étaient enfin
l'expérience que j'appelle attirer des
différentes lois qui ont programme qui
ont reconstruit petit à petit l'égalité
de droits entre les paroles des
personnes lgbt et les personnes
hétérosexuelles matière de filiation de
parentalité
dans un deuxième temps nous reviendrons
plus précisément sur ce que la loi votée
en première lecture à l'assemblée à
porte de positif et ce qu'elle apporte
évidemment parce qu'elle est de plus
négatif
est ce que nous souhaiterions évidemment
voir évoluer pour s'inscrire résolument
dans une dans un état de droit pour tout
le monde donc la pgl rapidement a créé
en 1986 est la plus ancienne
c'est la plus la plus large sociation
homoparentales qui existe en france et a
créé l'homoparentalité le maul vocable
on peut le rendre moins cet hommage là
elle est présente sur toute la france
elle est et reconnaît son action est
reconnue dans tout le champ de
l'homoparentalité aussi bien donc
et je rappelle parce que c'est important
on entend ça allait faire passer à la
trappe mais les situations donc les
familles homoparentales qui sont nés en
fait d'une situation de ce qu'on appelle
nouvel ex hétéros les situations
homoparentales qui sont nés de
l'adoption l'adoption conjointe agrément
évidemment les famines et de pma les
famines et le gpa
et puis tout ce qu'on peut associer
également dans le grand volume de la
coparentalité qui est aujourd'hui encore
la grande méconnu et des filiations et
des familles homoparentales dans notre
pays pour des raisons qui m'échappent
ceci étant posé donc la pga intervient
sur également dans le champ associatif
et l'ensemble en champ social avec la
reconnaissance et l'accompagnement des
familles et des futures familles mais
également dans le champ du politique et
à chaque fois l'objectif de la pgl et de
faire entendre trois choses la première
c'est que toute famille et toutes
personnes lgbt a droit à fonder une
famille en france
de la même façon que toute autre
personne quelle que soit son orientation
sexuelle le deuxième point important
c'est de s'assurer que tous les parents
et les mêmes droits et les mêmes droits
en termes de filiation quel que soit
leur statut quelle que soit l'heure
contribution au projet qui soit les
parents légaux ou les parents sociaux
nous réclamons une égalité des droits
pour tous ces parents là et enfin de
permettre à chacun des enfants de toute
famille homoparentale d'avoir le même
bien de sécuriser de filiation à l'égard
de tous ses parents encore une fois
quelle que soit la place du parent ou le
rôle du parent qui a mené à réaliser la
famille m la pga est un acteur reconnu
depuis très longtemps aussi bien dans
monde associatif que par les poids
politique dans le monde associatif elle
est reconnue depuis son origine pour ces
combat qu'elle a mené un cadre des
luttes contre les discriminations et
plus récemment grâce à la lotto dira
elle est reconnue elle intervient
également dans le champ politique de
manière un peu plus institutionnalisé
puisque jusqu'à la loi taubira et à
l'aller toutes les institutions la
république qui traitait des questions de
famille il était quasiment interdite
on va pas revenir sur l'épisode de glee
l'affc d'un sujet du passé on peut donc
laisser au musée est donc depuis 2014
la pga a évidemment une place occupe une
place de choix je dirais pour des
raisons très simples ailleurs à raison à
la fois de la force que lui donne de ces
cons ses adhérents ses adhérents et ses
familles dire tous ces gens nous font
remonter leurs besoins et donc la force
de la pj et c'est de se nourrir de ses
besoins pour aller effectivement me
demander aux pouvoirs publics de
réfléchir aux situations et surtout de
permettre à chacun de réaliser son
projet de famille à l'égalité de droit
c'est une force qui est très importante
puisque grâce à sa mixité est évidemment
et grâce à sa diversité
elle fait remonter des sujets qui
peuvent être entendus différemment selon
que les associations par exemple sont
plutôt typé sur tel et tel type de
famille et la pj n'a pas de type de
famille la page elle embrasse toutes les
familles et de ce fait elle a toute
légitimité pour intervenir sur le champ
qui nous concerne et en terme et est
demandé pour la paix mais en tous les
cas que la loi soit plus encore
égalitaire qu'elle ne le ghana et eva
canole en sortant de cette première
lecture elle a différents moyens à pgel
pour se faire entendre
notamment elle organise des débats
notamment elle a fait produire un film
qui s'appelle mon enfant ma bataille qui
retrace toutes ces histoires et qui
explique très très bien par exemple les
parcours pma et les difficultés qu'ont
les familles en pma pour obtenir en fait
sereinement rézé sereinement leur projet
nous sommes donc présents dans
différentes instances eux
de la république à l'unaf et dans les u9
au conseil un famille et aussi au sein
de collectifs gbt du dd et j'en passe et
ce qui nous permet d'avoir une vue
d'ensemble des questions et de pouvoir
intervenir là où jusqu'à présent ces
questions n'étaient pas nécessairement
poser et je dois dire d'ailleurs que à
cette occasion il a été en temps et nous
a été amené à retient de la discuter
donc avec les instances unaf et le
président du haut conseil de la famille
je suis un sujet très précis que nous
allons aborder tout à l'heure qui est la
question de cette exclusion du droit
commun de la filière des questions de
filiation pour les seuls couples des
femmes qui accéderait la pma et je dois
dire que nos interlocuteurs ont été tout
autant surpris que nous que l'assemblée
nationale vote
un tel système et ne comprendrait pas je
pense qu'on le maintienne
on y reviendra au delà de ça je voudrais
également partager avec vous
l'expérience de la pgl depuis en fait
ses premières lois qui ont permis
graduellement d'obtenir des deux tiers
des droits et d'égalité qui a commencé
par le pacs depuis toujours la pga a
défendu que quelles que soient les
statuts quels que soient les projets de
loi qui devait contribuer à donner des
mêmes droits aux personnes lgbt qu'il
fallait inclure les questions de famille
et questions de parentalité
elle a participé la pgl avec force de
proposition pour être pour obtenir que
ces questions soient incluses dans ces
différents systèmes dans ces différentes
réformes et malheureusement elle a dû
faire face à ce que j'appellerais une
tendance de fond de notre faim de huy
tendance de fond de notre pays c'est un
nous donne et permettre aux personnes
lgbt d'avoir un peu de droit mais
surtout pas plus que les autres et le
droit qu'on leur donne on s'assure que
il sera bien spécifiques
donc à chaque fois à chaque fois qu'il a
été question de grande loi d'égalité à
chaque fois et on ne sommes retrouvés
confrontés à des situations où en fait
on nous donnait le droit par la porte
arrière pour accéder au salon l'égalité
on se demande bien encore pourquoi le
pacs par exemple pacs nous a été proposé
vendue comme étant une mesure d'égalité
autre hétéro homo
certes mais en 2099 lorsqu'il était
votée et les hétéros eux avaient la
possibilité se marier pas les
homosexuels et le pacs ne couvrait
évidemment pas du tout le champ de la
filiation donc encore une fois on a posé
un système qu'il a fallu en fait faire
évoluer les juristes que non seulement
fait évoluer les mentalités il en fait
évoluer mais on a donné on a donné aux
personnes concernées et je reviendrai
sera question avec le mariage des
éléments pour faire un peu d'égalité
mais surtout pour se débrouiller de ce
qu'on n'avait pas obtenu en termes
d'égalité et encore une fois j'ai peur
que la loi qui a été votée en première
lecture n'aboutisse à ce statut le souci
que nous avons évidemment c'est
d'obtenir que le cac small qui vous est
soumis représente et reflète un maximum
d'égalité alors donc c'est bien vous
avez respecté votre temps
je vais donner la parole à van hamme
picarda c'est vrai qu'on s'est donné aux
dix minutes par intervenants mais en
vous laissant tout le loisir de
développer ensuite vos réponses auprès
des rapporteurs ou d autres sénatrices
et sénateurs
d'ailleurs effectivement nous sommes
nous même venu d'en but d'échanger et
c'est donc avec plaisir que nous
attendons les questions ce que nous ce
que nous ce que vous a rappelé la mesure
bohren sont des principes fondamentaux
auxquels nous sommes extrêmement
attachés
nous sommes d'abord et avant tout
attentifs et soucieux que la loi reflète
l'esprit notre république c'est à dire
qu'elle nous donne la liberté l'égalité
et qu'elle repose sur les principes de
fraternité c'est vraiment ce que nous
attendons de cette loi malheureusement
nous ne sommes pas tout à fait engager
dans ce dans cette direction est ce que
racontait que vous rappeler tout à
l'heure monsieur morin c'est exactement
l'expérience que nous avons de ce que
quand la loi n'est pas tout à fait
égalitaire et qu'elle crée des sous
catégories de citoyens
elle crée des difficultés particulières
et des souffrances qui vont avec
nous l'avons expérimenté avec le pacs
qui n'a évidemment pas suffi puisque les
homosexuels étaient privés du mariage et
de la filiation dans le cadre du mariage
qui est un mariage égalitaire du point
de vue de la conjugalité nous avons fait
l'expérience d'un mariage qui n'était
pas égalitaire du point de vue de la
filiation et qui a mille nombreuses
familles en souffrance
ces familles les nous avions averti
législateur aussi bien l'assemblée
nationale qu'au sénat que une loi qui ne
seraient pas suffisantes pour établir
les filiations dans le cadre des
mariages entraînerait des souffrances et
entraînerait des difficultés pour les
familles à se voir considérer de manière
égalitaire dans les tribunaux quelques
mois après dès que les premières
familles ont pu se présenter devant les
tribunaux
nous avons vu remonter des difficultés
extrêmes et des familles qui se sont
trouvés violentées dans les dents les
dans leurs propres tribunaux dans les
rues nom de leur pays parce qu'elles
n'étaient pas reconnus alors que la loi
aurait dû le faire
nous avons donc du point de vue du
projet de loi qui a été votée à
l'assemblée nationale à la fois
évidemment une satisfaction qui ont déjà
été évoqués ici à savoir le vote de la
pma et le principe de l'ouverture à
toutes les femmes indépendamment de leur
situation matrimoniale et de leurs
conjoints ou qu'elle soit seule ou en
couple
là dessus évidemment nous sommes
extrêmement contents nous avons aussi
apprécié que la filiation du coup avec
ce projet soit pensez y compris pour les
homosexuels en dehors du mariage puisque
jusqu'à présent nous étions cantonnés à
cette idée là et à ce principe là ce qui
ne nous convient pas puisqu'il s'agit
bien sûr là d'une rupture d'égalité
également nous sommes satisfaits du
principe de la prise en charge par la
sécurité sociale pour toutes les femmes
nous avons évidemment un certain nombre
de questions sur la manière dont les
prises en charges des des demandes de
pm1 seront validées et comment seront
organisées les prises en charge de ces
de ces couples mais peut-être que le
législateur pourra nous éclairer nous
rassurer sur la question et puis
également sur la possibilité d'accès des
éléments de connaissance sur les
donneurs que pour ma part je récuse a
appelé les origines parce que les
origines de l'enfant pour moi ne se
trouve pas dans un matériel génétique
mais bien plutôt dans l'histoire de
l'enfant qui lui est racontée par ses
parents et par l'histoire qui est la
sienne et quand il a été conçu par une
pme avec un don anonyme pas anonymes
semi anonyme
eh bien le certes sa vie sa vie découle
de ce capital génétique sans aucun doute
mais pour autant son histoire et donc
ses origines ne sont pas là en tout cas
pas pour l'essentiel donc avoir des
éléments de connaissance sur les
donneurs scène de paraît important c'est
que certains enfants sont en demande sur
ce sujet et il est dommage de leur
barrer la route et de les laisser
on va dire marine et par m voilà dans
une souffrance qui pourrait trouver une
issue rapide
si on leur donnait des connaissances
qu'il réclame mais en général d'ailleurs
le simple fait qu'on leur permette de
savoir qu'ils peuvent avoir accès à des
connaissances suffi à apaiser leur
curiosité
ils n'ont pas forcément besoin d'aller
au delà sont des retours qu'on a deux
pays étrangers par exemple
voilà notre notre nos inquiétudes repose
aujourd'hui sur l'un constat extrêmement
dépité je dois dire est extrêmement
étonné de ce que le législateur a tenté
dans un premier temps de faire en sorte
que nos revendications pâtissent à
d'autres cas nous c'est à dire les
couples hétérosexuels qui avaient
recours aux pma et pour profiter de le
changement de la loi pour les faire
sortir du cadre alors qu'ils n'avaient
rien demandé à personne du cadre dans
lequel il était à l'abri dans le cadre
de la loi française depuis des décennies
et pour d'un seul coup menacée je trouve
que ça on entendait ça comme un forme
une menace d'inscrire les le mode de
conception sur l'état civil des enfants
nous avons toujours fait savoir que nous
étions opposés à ce principe là peut il
n'ya rien égalitaire là dedans pour nous
est que quand des gens n'ont rien
demandé il n'est pas question de leur
imposer quelque chose alors que depuis
que l'e pm1 pour les hétéros fonctionne
elle fonctionne bien elles n'ont jamais
donné lieu à des contestations notamment
en termes de filiation n'est qu'on voit
pas pourquoi on sortira les gens de
droit commun
notre revendication à nous elle est
républicaine je voulais dit elle va dans
le sens de l'égalité
nous voulons passer le plus possible et
si possible dans la totalité dans le
droit commun de la filiation et surtout
on vient nous avons constaté qu on nous
propose d'un seul coup quelque chose qui
était tout à fait inattendu c'est qu'on
vient penser un mode d'établissement de
la filiation qui serait réservée aux
femmes
homosexuel qui viendrait à coller les
deux maires ensemble dans un même
mouvement d'établissement d'affiliation
comme si chacune ne pouvait pas
l'établir indépendamment de l'autre et
qui vient priver la mer qui va accoucher
de la possibilité de faire établir son
affiliation avec son enfant par
l'accouchement comme c'est le cas pour
toutes autres femmes et alors c'est vrai
on veut dire que nous sommes absolument
contre voilà que d'un seul coup au nom
d'une avancée des droits on vient priver
une femme de son de son droit d'établir
la filiation comme une autre
si on ne déclare pas qu'elle est en
couple avec une femme elle établit sa
filiation une certaine manière si elle
ne déclare et bien les priver de voir sa
filiation établie par l'accouchement
d'autre part il ne paraît beaucoup plus
simple que l'engagement il faut penser
les choses de cette manière là
l'engagement dans la pma n'est pas du
tout équivalent à l'établissement de la
filiation
l'engagement dans la pma va obliger
contraindre et et donner des droits aux
deux femmes de manière équivalente
équivalente
ce ne sont pas pour autant exactement
les mêmes droits puisque l'une des fins
établira sa finition de certaines
manières et l'autre d'une autre nous
avons des modèles nous avons des modèles
à l'étranger mais nous avons des modèles
en france les personnes qui font des pma
et qu'ils sont hétérosexuels en france
ne sont pas privés de ce droit là les
femmes accouchent et établissent leur
filiation
voilà sans discrimination de cette
manière là quand on perd ils n'ont pas
le lien biologique avec l'enfant mais
ils sont garantis dans l'établissement
de leur filiation et dans le lien avec
leurs enfants par le fait qu'ils ont
accepté le principe de la pma écoute du
coup ils sont susceptibles d' établir
leur filiation
comme tout autre homme dans le cadre du
droit commun de la filiation et de la
famille en france donc c'est ce que nous
voudrions voir établi monsieur borhane
vous a rappelé que nous avons une longue
expérience nous avons constaté depuis
des années qu à créer des petits droit
on est toujours obligé d'y revenir
on y revient après de nombreuses
souffrances et de nombreux dégâts dans
les familles et notamment sur le dos de
nos enfants et que par ailleurs à mettre
à ouvrir des droits des petits droits
spécifiques comme ça eh bien d'abord le
législateur introduire dans la loi lui
même des discriminations c'est à dire
faudrait introduire l on a un droit qui
n'a aucun rapport avec la situation de
la personne en quoi la sexualité de la
mer doit-elle induire que années privée
de droit qui sont ouverts aux autres
femmes
c'est une question mais en ouvrant des
petits droit comme ça on met les gens
dans des tiroirs et dans des catégories
qui n'ont rien à voir avec le principe
du droit ont créé autant de droit qu'il
ya de cas et des régimes spécifiques
dans lesquels tout le monde se perd
alors que le plus simple c'est d'ouvrir
les portes de notre grande maison
républicaine et de les ouvrir à tout le
monde sans discrimination je me rappelle
que les personnes homosexuelles sont
aujourd'hui considérés quand même
heureusement comme des citoyens comme
les autres qui participent à l'effort
national de toutes les manières en
travaillant en faisant des enfants en
cotisant la sécurité sociale dont ils
n'ont pas pour le moment tous les droits
et qu'il n'y a pas de raison en tout cas
moi je pense que des sénateurs doivent
vraiment sincèrement considérées qui n'a
aucune raison de créer des petits droit
à part toujours pour les personnes
homosexuelles pour les femmes qui
accouchent en raison de l'orientation
sexuelle et privé la deuxième mère dans
l'établissement de la filiation d'une
manière simple par un processus de
reconnaissance qui sera rock qui
reposera sur le fait que allah elle
s'est engagée dans un processus de paix
m 1 et que du coup ça lui ouvre à la
fois des droits et des devoirs
je pense que je vous ai dit l'essentiel
de ce que de ce que nous voulons nous ne
voulons pas d'un droit qui viennent
ouvrir d'autres formes d'exclusion on va
ouvrir le débat donc par un échange
notamment premier lieu avec les
rapporteurs ai je donné la parole à
madame muriel jourda
merci à le président oui j'ai une
question en réalité un peu à tout le
monde enfin tous ceux qui voudront bien
y répondre d'ailleurs puisque vous avez
tous à tour de rôle évoquer la notion
d'égalité et son pendant qu'ils aient la
discrimination
or plusieurs ministres et plusieurs
juridictions ont indiqué qu'il n'y avait
pas d'égalité en fait dans l'extension
de la mp aux femmes seules et aux femmes
homosexuelles dans la mesure où et bien
il n'y avait pas non plus 10
me nation à traiter différemment des
personnes qui étaient dans une situation
différente et qu'en réalité les femmes
seules ou les femmes homosexuelles
n'était pas dans la même situation de
fait que des couples hétérosexuels face
à la procréation
donc je voulais d'abord avoir vos
observations là dessus ensuite vous
indiquez que vous souhaitez pouvoir
bénéficier du droit commun le droit
commun de la mg et donc qui existent
aujourd'hui pour les et les couples
hétérosexuels
j'ai conscience que ma question est
peut-être un petit peu de technique et
et si vous ne pouvez pas nier qu'il n'y
a pas de difficultés mais aujourd'hui
pour les couples hétérosexuels mariés le
droit commun c'est en fait que la femme
accouche elle est la mère et le père
devient père par le biais de la
présomption de paternité
comment pouvez-vous transcrire cela pour
un couple homosexuel
voilà ce sont mes deux questions merci
qui veut commencer même chainel malaisie
je veux bien commencer par la première
le fait de dire que ce sont des
situations différentes donnent à des
droits différents c'est en effet une
résidence mais il faut savoir qu'elles
évoluent elles évoluent en fonction de
ce que la société conseil considère
comme des situations différentes
par exemple pendant longtemps on a
considéré que le mariage homosexuel
comme c'était dès que les couples
hétérosexuels et couples homosexuels
étaient des situations différentes ce
qui justifiait pour certains d'avoir le
mariage et pour d'autres de ne pas la
voir
cette conception a évolué et c'est
exactement ce qu'il se passe maintenant
pour les familles homoparentales c'est à
dire que au regard du don on a un parent
qui a un lien biologique avec l'enfant
en général un parent qu'il n'a pas est
ce que le sexe de ses parents est une
différence de situation suffisante
nous nous considérons que non certains
considérant sans doute que oui je pense
que le sens de l'évolution du droit va
plutôt vers le fait qu'on ne considèrera
que ce que ce n'est pas une que la
différence ne justifie pas un droit
différent
la différence n'est pas suffisante
je vous en prie madame ceresoli
oui alors sur les deux aspects donc le
premier aspect sur la différence de
situation
donc vous avez effectivement précisément
différence de situation par rapport à la
procréation
nous nous plaçons nous évidemment là sur
la similarité de situation face à la
conception c'est à dire un couple qui
aurait donc accès à la mp avec donneur
il y aurait donc dans ce couple une
personne qui porte l'enfant et qui
accouche donc sa filiation devrait être
effectivement égale à toutes les autres
personnes qui accouchent et pour le
second parent donc non géniteur encore
une fois qu'ils soient hommes ou femmes
et là je donc rejoint lorraine en chine
elle n'a pas d'incidence en regard de
droit et en droit par rapport à
l'établissement d'une filiation ce
second parent n'est pas génétiquement
liés à cet enfant qu'il soit homme ou
femme et là on rebondit sur la notion
d'égalité dans notre droit qui a encore
beaucoup pas avancé mais en regard de la
conception de cet enfant et deux parents
qu'ils soient hommes ou femmes qui ne
sont pas liées génétiquement à cette
enfant sont exactement dans une
situation similaire selon est par contre
donc je sur le deuxième point pardon sur
la présomption de paternité
il semble hélas il ya des
interprétations de droit c'est bien
toute la richesse du droit moi je ne
suis pas juriste mais mais nous en avons
consulté aussi beaucoup et des
doctorants droit donc je pense que vous
savez déjà après les auditions de toute
façon qu'il ya des interprétations
différentes
mais le père dans le cadre d'une amp
avec don est présumé père parce que mari
de la femme qui accouche à partir du
moment où en deux
la femme serait donc marié à la femme
qui accouche serait présumé par an par
le mariage et lors d'un mariage civil
donc un mariage devant la république les
officiers d'état civil disent bien les
articles inhérents à l'accueil des
enfants au sein du couple marié donc
encore une fois dans un couple marié la
présomption de parentalité découlerait
du mariage avec la femme qui accouche et
pour les couples non mariés donc d'une
reconnaissance
merci merci pour vos questions madame le
rapporteur évidemment sur le premier
sujet concernant l'égalité des droits
j'entends fin plus tôt j'ai pas entendu
mais j'ai compris vous faisait référence
à l'avis du conseil d'état
puisque dans l'avis du conseil d'état il
est clairement indiqué qu'effectivement
il n'y a pas nécessité d'ouvrir la pma
toutes les femmes que ça ne constitue ni
une attaque finalement sur la la la
liberté d'être de vivre ni une
discrimination puisque on ne parle pas
de la même chose pour résumer d'avis du
conseil des tags donc ouvrir ou pas
finalement il n'y avait aucune
indication particulière du conseil
d'état sur une voie où sur une voie
différente
alors pour répondre à votre question
l'égalité des droits c'est un choix
politique c'est un choix républicain si
c'était un droit
le mariage pour les couples de même sexe
seraient imposées par la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme dans tous les
états soumis à la convention
si en france il y avait un droit de
l'enfant les femmes hétérosexuels qui ne
peuvent plus porter d'enfant parce
qu'elles n'ont plus d'utérus
elles seraient des premières discriminés
par rapport aux autres et y aurait la
gpa depuis 40 ans donc on voit bien
qu'il nie un droit effectivement basé
sur une discrimination qui découlerait
d'une conséquence donc juridique
je reviens sur l'avis du conseil d'état
ni une un système encore une fois qui
serait organisée par rapport à une
définition relative à une décision de
justice que ça soit le problème des
droits de l'homme la cour de cassation
conseil d'état mais c'est bien
l'initiative politique
on a eu l'ouverture du mariage
pour tous les couples parce que le
législateur s'est emparé de la du sujet
et il a fait voter
on l'a pas eue par une décision de la
cour de cassation on l'a pas eue par la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
donc c'est bien ça valait bien une
initiative politique sur le sujet du
droit commun je pense que je rejoins
votre votre opinion et d'ailleurs c'est
cette opinion comme quoi le droit
l'extension du droit commun serait une
une possibilité pour nous c'est pas une
possibilité c'est une imposture
clairement nous disons clairement
pourquoi parce que comme vous le savez
le titre cette île est basé sur le
rapport charnel oups 2h charnelle où
monsieur et monsieur parce qu'on imagine
qu'il est dans ledit de madame et que
l'enfant en est le fruit
lorsqu on transpose ça pour des couples
lesbiens pardonnez moi mais ça ne
fonctionne pas donc on ne peut pas
transposer cette disposition pour pour
ses enfants et enfin je reviens toujours
avec mon histoire de prisme que je vous
demande de porter d'avoir le prisme de
l'intérêt de l'enfant et non pas le
prisme de l'intérêt des parents comme ma
petite référence tout à l'heure à la
circulaire de 1950 puisse être qu'il a
invalidé en 1966 donc si on garde ce
prisme de l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant
eh bien on considère encore une fois que
tous les enfants nés du don doivent être
égalité de droit peu importe qu'ils
aient des parents homosexuels ou
hétérosexuels peu importe qu'ils soient
mariés ou non on se base au niveau de
l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant est on
est on crée et d'ailleurs la ministre a
utilisé le mot révolution et ont créé un
système une modalités d'établissement
filiation qui est valable pour tous ces
enfants nés du don comme on a créé de
titres 8 pour l'adoption dans le code
civil
on n'a pas stigmatiser les enfants qui
sont adoptés on n'a jamais dit que parce
qu'ils avaient une mention leur jugement
d'adoption sur l'or sur l'extrait de
naissance sur par non pas sur leur style
des gens sur leurs actes intégrale de
naissance et bien ces enfants étaient
stigmatisés
alors bien sûr on peut créer un stigmate
pour le pour mieux le dénoncer ensuite
mais nous avec les associations du
collectif auquel nous sommes je répète
enfin je les nomme permettez-moi donc
centré go clara des cigognes de l'espoir
maya pm anonymes comme la plus grosse
association d'enfants nés de dons un cce
qu'il faut écouter ceux qui sont les
premiers concernés et des réseaux ferrés
dit fertilité france et l'association
italia nous disons clairement que nous
ne vous
non pas de l'extension du droit commun
et que nous voulons l'extension de la
reconnaissance conjointe anticipé pour
tous les enfants
c'est ça l'égalité merci madame de votre
question en ce qui concerne
effectivement la référence à l'idée du
conseil d'état il ya effectivement deux
choses à repérer me semble-t-il d'abord
que nous sommes dans un temps politique
i qui est différent et qui permet en
effet aujourd'hui l'ouverture de droits
à des personnes en reconnaissant leurs
spécificités de la même manière que les
hommes et les femmes sont différents et
pourtant on le reconnaît un certain
nombre de droits à l'identique
simplement parce qu'on ne fait pas
valoir des spécificités là où elles
n'ont pas lieu d'être
quand une femme a recours à une pma
qu'elle soit homosexuel ou hétérosexuel
le processus médical est strictement le
même
la grossesse est strictement la même
l'accouchement se passera de la même
manière et pas de différence entre une
femme homosexuelle ou hétérosexuelle qui
accouchent ou qui porte un enfant et on
ne voit pas pourquoi on viendrait du
coup à ce moment-là créer une divergence
dans l'établissement du droit en raison
de l'orientation sexuelle de la mer
c'est exactement le principe de
discrimination c'est pas tenir compte
d'une différence parce que c'est
accroché une différence là où elle n'a
pas lieu d'être et du coup enfer
découler des droits ou des non droit
alors que le rideau sexuelle de la mer
n'a aucun rapport avec le fait qu'elle
porte qu'elle est prête quand même à
quelle porte l'enfant qu'elle accouche
et qu'elles soient plus tard une mère
comme les autres donc venir introduire
au nom d'une différence une différence
de traitement un jury dic alors que ça
n'a pas lieu d'être
ça me semble extrêmement problématique
quand le notamment pour ce qui est de la
question de la filiation par
l'accouchement
pour ce qui est de la deuxième partie
qui est finalement l'objet de votre
deuxième question est qui et comment on
établir la filiation à l'égard de la
deuxième mère
alors là pour le coup en effet on est
dans une situation différente puisque
elle deviendra maire non pas par
l'accouchement mais du coup par le fait
qu'elle elle est engagée à l'égard de
l'enfant notamment dans le processus de
paix m 1 et en raison du mariage il ya
deux solutions soit on valide
l'extension de la présomption de
paternité à une présentation qu
maternité par le fait qu'on considère
qu'il y a un
comment dire une présomption qui repose
sur le l'engagement liés au mariage et
c'est le mariage au fond qui valide par
principe un comme un père reconnaît par
principe est automatiquement considéré
comme le père de ses enfants
indépendamment du fait qu'on lui demande
pas de faire un test adn pour chaque
enfant et de vérifier qu'il ya bien un
filet lancé la situation du mariage qui
bien évidemment repose en général sur
une réalité biologique et sur une
réalité concrète mais c'est là la
situation du mariage qui créée la
filiation par principe
donc on peut tout à fait penser que
cette situation puisse être élargi mais
de toute façon il faudrait envisager une
situation autre qui sera la situation de
la reconnaissance par la deuxième mère
qu'il a pour le coup peut tout à fait se
calquer sur la situation qui est faite
une situation de reconnaissance qui
serait validée par le fait de
l'engagement dans la pme pour elle est
uniquement pour elle on n'a pas à coller
les deux modes de filiation des deux
mers en même temps quelque chose qui ne
s'est jamais vu et qui viendrait à être
là créé uniquement comme une boîte à
outils spécifiques pour les couples de
femmes
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui fait la
filiation de l'une et de l'autre c'est
de s'être engagé en même temps dans le
parcours de la paix m ça c'est ce ne
sommes pas bons du tout c'est le
principe même de l'usiné à gaz
alors que là il pourrait tout à fait
possible d'envisager la possibilité
d'une reconnaissance en mairie sur le
principe de l'engagement dans le
parcours de la pma et qui sera validée
par un papier par le notaire et ses
armes et sans inscription 1 sur le coup
pour le coup c'est l'inscription à
l'état civil
parce qu'en effet il faut penser à
l'intérêt des enfants et qui n'est pas
dans l'intérêt des enfants que figure
sur leur acte de naissance un certain
nombre de mentions qui n'ont rien à voir
avec leur état civil ni leur filiation
le mode de procréation ne doit pas faire
partie de ce qui figure explicitement
sur un acte de naissance donc là que
dire que la deuxième mère est la mère
puisqu'elle a reconnu l'enfant
bon ben voilà c'est parce que c'est
ainsi que c'est habile et finition ça a
un rapport avec l'établissement de la
filiation et non pas avec autre chose
qui est le monde
conception je vous remercie madame ça
vous convient donc je vais passer la
parole à notre deuxième rapportant mais
c'est bernard jomier merci merci à vous
tous et toutes pour vous vous exposez
l'ouverture de l'accès à la pma va se
conjuguer je crois que c'est assez
inédit à la modification dans l'acte est
dans le droit à l'accès aux origines et
donc va créer une situation d'un besoin
probablement quantitativement plus
important de gamètes et potentiellement
d'une modification de la typologie des
donneurs
quels sont vos réflexions à ce sujet et
quelles propositions avez vous pour
qu'on évite une situation de pénurie qui
serait préjudiciable à tout le monde et
j'ai une deuxième question partir mans
pour madame chainel pascal aborder ce
point
vous avez évoqué l'article 14 et le
statut de l'embryon en indiquant que ça
vous posez vous aviez des réserves est
ce que vous pourriez nous les expliciter
je vous remercie
alors à qui dois-je donner la parole
pour la première question de monsieur
juillet ou alors si madame chainel veut
répondre à la directement la deuxième
question
simplement monsieur en demandant à
l'état de prendre ses responsabilités
me semble-t-il qu'on pourra ne pas se
trouver devant une situation de pénurie
de gamètes
on sait très bien qu'aujourd'hui la
situation est tendue en ce qui concerne
les dons de gamètes dont de don de
spermatozoïdes ou d'ovocytes ou dons
d'embryons
parce que
l'état notamment ne fait pas de
publicité au sens large du terme bien
sûr sur ces questions là il est
important d'éduquer une population c'est
la responsabilité de l'état d'éduquer la
population et de l'éduquer à la
solidarité à l'égard des personnes qui
ont besoin de dons et donc de favoriser
des essais donc la responsabilité
d'ailleurs des législateurs de favoriser
des des informations et des campagnes
d'informations sûres sur ces points-là
beaucoup pour nous bon par ailleurs je
pense pas non plus que le va y avoir une
une déferlante sur les cecos de femmes
homosexuelles qui va demander des des
des pma je pense malheureusement qui
donnera même encore beaucoup qui iront à
l'étranger notamment parce que de toute
façon déjà les temps d'attentes sont
extrêmement longs notre question à noël
est plutôt de savoir si les femmes qui
viendront et qui se présenteront seront
traités à égalité
et de quelle manière elles seront
traitées dans l'est dans les centres e
et si les les délais qui leur seront
données seront les mêmes que tout le
monde
bon il y aura il y aura des
modifications de profil des donneurs
peut-être sans doute même mais pour
autant je pense à monsieur justice ne
justifie pas la destruction des gamètes
comme l avait été envisagé un temps un
je pense qu'il faut respecter
l'engagement qui a été donnée à ces
personnes et leur donner et donner le
temps de décoller leurs gamètes guitare
comme le propose en un temps la ministre
passé par des périodes probatoires enfin
entre deux raies que proposer à des
personnes la possibilité d'un don
anonyme ou pas le temps que les nouveaux
donneurs puisqu'ils sont prêts à ne pas
être resté complètement anonymes ou a
donné un certain nombre d'informations
puissent se manifester
très bien alors sur la même question
peut-être c'est ceresoli oui pour
répondre à cette question je un tout
petit éclairage mais que vous avez déjà
eu certainement avant donc je crois
qu'aujourd'hui le nombre des donneurs
est autour de 350 sur une population de
je sais pas combien on est maintenant
mai 68 69 millions voilà donc je pense
qu'effectivement cette cette question du
nombre de donneurs pour être facilement
adressées par les pouvoirs publics et là
je rejoins tout à fait marie claude
picarda et notamment aussi sur le
changement de la société sur le regard
sur le don et sur les donc famille nées
de dmp également je crois que je suis
pas statisticienne mais l'insee avait
été auditionnée au sein de l'assemblée
nationale je ne sais pas si vous les
avez reçu ici dans cette commission
mais enfin il avait sorti effectivement
des chiffres pour montrer à quel point
quelques dizaines de donneurs en plus
suffirait à répondre à la demande
anticipée supplémentaire de ton espèce
merci à ce que madame michaud veut
compléter oui très rapidement car
beaucoup de choses ont déjà été dites
mais effectivement je pense qu'il faut
déjà complètement abandonné l'idée
la destruction du stock existence c'est
fondamental et puis
et puis et puis aller chercher des
nouveaux donneurs ça passe aussi on
l'avait rappelé l'époque au moment des
auditions par le ccdh
ça passe aussi par des vraies campagnes
de communication des communications
grand public en l'état enfin rares sont
les français lambda qui ont déjà entendu
parler des campagnes qui existent donc
je pense à des dés
des campagnes un peu du même acabit que
pour le don de sang ces terres des
campagnes vraiment grand public ne
rapplique voilà pour un homme donner ses
gamètes ça peut ça existe et que ça peut
se faire dans une démarche altruiste
puisqu'on parle bien de deux dents dont
sur la même question sur la première oui
trois porter un éclairage complémentaire
par rapport au stock et finalement à
l'impact du changement de régime
d'anonymat sur sur les donneurs au
royaume uni le changement législatif une
intervenue en 2005
en disant ça a doublé en suède
le nombre de donneurs s'il a connu une
baisse l'année suivant la réforme qui
est intervenu en 1984 il a retrouvé son
niveau antérieur dès les années
suivantes et il a continué à progresser
donc ya pas vraiment d'inquiétude sur ce
sujet agiter des chiffons rouges mais on
voit bien que dans les autres pays
voisins ce sujet là n'en est plus à
aujourd'hui effectivement une phase
transitoire qui pourraient être impactés
sur un nom
mais on voit très très rapidement que ce
niveau remonte sur les années qui
suivent oui vous avez raison je pense
que cette anxiété qu'on a par rapport au
stock doit être mesurée auprès des des
experts que peuvent être les professeurs
notamment de centres je me souviens d'un
petit déjeuner que nous avons eues avec
le professeur ayoubi un qui nous disait
que la meilleure façon c'était aussi
d'entraîner au don toutes ces familles
qui sont en difficulté par rapport à
l'obtention de gamètes et donc à cette
sensibilisation fait en sorte
généralement m d'avoir de nouveaux
donneurs oui vous avez raison d'ailleurs
on peut aussi compléter en disant qu
actuellement dans le modèle de
bioéthique sur le don d'ovocytes où on
l'a rappelé il peut y avoir jusqu'à
parfois plus de trois ans d'attentes
gerra même plus comment une c5 venir
avec une autre femme qui va donner ses
propres ovocytes sans pour autant
utiliser les siens puisque on reste sur
sur l'anonymat permet de réduire de
thiais ce délai et c'est presque ans
excusez moi du terme mais c'est presque
un deal qui est fait entre celles qui
pourront venir avec une autre femme qui
va pouvoir faire un don qui vont donc
lui faire bénéficier de 50% d'un délai
qui aurait dû être de 5 et qui va passer
à deux et demi par rapport aux autres
on pourrait aussi avoir ce système là
sur le don de gamètes si vraiment été
payant en pénurie maintenant par rapport
au stock actuel nous on s'oriente plus
vers une situation où on pourrait c'est
bien que par rapport à certains cecos ça
devient extrêmement problématique mais
beaucoup plus pour des raisons
proprement administrative en réalité
contre que de raisons idéologiques mais
contacté ceux qui ont donné pour savoir
s'ils veulent rentrer dans le nouveau
régime ou non ça serait aussi un moyen
ne pas détruire totalement le stock
si le stock actuel et les donneurs qu'on
pourrait recontacter consentent à
rentrer dans le nouveau régime il
pourrait être dix peuvent tout à fait
dire non seulement détruit mais s'ils
consentent à rentrer dans le nouveau
régime pourquoi on devrait détruire ses
gamètes
très bien alors je les sais maintenant
la parole chainel oui alors justement
quelques éléments là dessus comme vous
l'avez dit en fait la grosse pénurie
actuellement elle est sur le don
d'ovocytes donc on peut même penser
comme actuellement ce qui donne c'est
souvent ceux qui sont dans des processus
de paix m a que plus l'entrée des femmes
et des femmes célibataires et des
lesbiennes peut pourra faire monter
potentiellement le don d'ovocytes
actuellement le don de gamètes cdh à peu
près entre 250 et 350 pour les hommes
par an et 500 500 femmes qui donnent
leurs ovocytes et surtout ce qui est
important c'est quand même le stock
c'est 90 mille paillettes c'est à dire
13 ans à l'identique
si on si on ouvre aux femmes
célibataires et aux lesbiennes on deck
steam ça va doubler donc on a six ans et
demi de stock donc alors pourquoi est ce
qu'on attend eh bien on attend parce
qu'en fait dans certains centres
on estime que attendre c'est bon pour la
maturation du projet parental
imaginez ce qu'on en pense quand ça fait
déjà qu en général surtout pour les
hétérosexuels plusieurs années qu'elle
est qu'ils essaient d'avoir des enfants
et c'est aussi parce qu'ils ont pas les
moyens d fois de recontacter les
donneurs et parce qu'ils fonctionnent
tous en sens unique terre que ils sont
ils sont tous autonomes
y'a pas
liaisons nationales et de répartition du
stock au niveau national donc il ya
vraiment des problèmes d'organisation et
on attend beaucoup du rapport
parlementaire sur ce sur ce sujet il y a
pour répondre ensuite à la donc ré
interroger les anciens donneurs comme ça
s'est fait à l'étranger
ça serait vraiment et ne pas détruire le
stock de ceux qui sont ok on comprend
pas pourquoi pourquoi on ne fait pas ça
d'autant que certains envisagent par
contre de les contacter pour demander
s'ils acceptent de donner à des coupes
suivant leur orientation sexuelle ce qui
pose quand même quelques soucis en terme
de discrimination parce qu'on pourrait
le faire aussi pour le don du sang tant
qu on y est enfin on donne mais pas pour
les homos s'enchaînant sur la question
du statut de l'embryon ce qui nous
embête c'est qu'en fait dans l'article
14 cantons réfère aux embryons on parle
systématiquement des embryons conçus en
vertu des articles 16 à 16,8 du code
civil
sauf que ces articles du code civil
il concerne les personnes ce que le
droit français considèrent comme une
personne qui est né vivant et viable et
donc demande ça donne en fait cette
raccourci donne une personnalité à
l'embryon ce qui pose des questions par
rapport à keur aliou vg tout ça c'est
une question que nous portons avec le
planning familial et le professeur
jouanno en particulier qui nous a
alertés très bien je vous remercie je
vais passer la parole maintenant
rapporteur monsieur olivier nous oui
merci madame la présidente
merci mesdames messieurs pour vous
exposer ma question concerne l'accès aux
origines pour les enfants qui vont
naître selon la mp on a déjà bien
évidemment c'est cet accès aux origines
et est de nature tout à fait différente
que
pour les enfants qui sont adoptés
puisque enfants nés sous amp sont je
crois en tout les cas je le crois
personnellement désiré aimé et donc
c'est de nature différente cette
recherche des origines mais vous avez
tout à l'heure évoquer cette personne
mais sous amp en 1995 mais pensez vous
que ce soit ce se soit le cna up qui
doit être responsable de cet accès aux
origines ou pensez vous qu'il faille
confier cette responsabilité à une autre
structure
alors comme une commission est prévue là
dans le projet de loi
l'intérêt c'est un peu ce qu'elle dit la
dépêche précédemment ça serait lui
donner en fait des des pouvoirs de
recherche similaire à celui du cna hop
pour les enfants passaient et puis lui
donner la mission pour les enfants
futurs
on pourrait toujours balancé sur le cnop
sauf que je crois que le cnop n'est pas
très désireux de ça et surtout en tout
cas pour l'instant il n'en a pas les
moyens financiers de voilà de traiter
tous segments mais en tout cas
s'inspirer de l'expérience du cna hop
est intéressante parce que ça montre
bien qu'on peut recontacter discrètement
des anciens donneurs puisque c'est déjà
fait et pourtant dans des situations qui
était bien plus dramatique que la
situation d'un don ou a priori en effet
ce sont des enfants désirés et c'est des
gens qui ont été heureux de
de données pour contribuer à un projet
parental vous avez des réponses aussi un
complément par rapport à cette réponse
qui peut être exprimé par par une
question en fait qui est finalement
beaucoup plus grave le dispositif est
très intéressant et permet de le
remonter à l'histoire personnelle accès
aux origines ses termes et comment je
sais moi si je suis né de dons ou pas
comment j'ai l'information qui me
prévient qui me garantit cet accès à mes
origines à mon histoire personnelle
la réponse dans le projet de loi allait
donner uniquement aux enfants qui seront
conçus par dont deux parents de même
sexe
les couples lesbo parentaux mais en
aucun cas aux enfants qui sont conçus
par couples hétérosexuels puisque
précisément on resterait dans le modèle
pseudo charnay l'établissement de la
filiation ont fait croire que ces
enfants étaient issus par le couple donc
avant même d'aborder votre question je
crois que la première des questions
c'est ce qu'on est ce que vous sénateurs
vous voulez donner cette même garantie
d'accès à tous les enfants peu importe
la sexualité des parents ce n'est pas le
sujet ou alors vous voulez continue de
discriminer est de créer une rupture
d'égalité en fonction de l'orientation
sexuelle de leurs parents pardon de vous
répondre avec une autre question mais je
crois qu'elle est aussi très importante
[Musique]
oui donc pour rebondir justement et
compléter les propos précédents jeux
j'en profite donc pour rebondir sur
justement notre incompréhension à ce
système de de reconnaissance conjointe
anticipé appliquée aux couples de femmes
puisque les enfants nés d'une amp avec
don dans un couple de femmes sont bien
justement les seuls enfants à ne pas
avoir besoin d'avoir une mention sur
quelques documents que ce soit pour
savoir qu'ils ont été conçus via un don
ou l'incompréhension
d'où nous notre association
l'interprétation qui est faite de la
primauté de l'hétéronormativité dans
notre droit et de ne surtout pas
rendre égale les familles homoparentales
aux familles hétérosexuelles qui est
donc pour nous de clairement une
discrimination et répondent
effectivement par un article 4 sur la
filiation entre un enfant et ses deux
mères à une question posée par l'article
3 est effectivement d'accès aux origines
qui est légitime aux pannes là dessus
nous n'avons pas de position mais en
tout cas répondre à une demande d'accès
aux origines
article 3 par un système de filiation
article 4 dents et uniquement les
familles composées de deux femmes
c'est totalement incompréhensible pour
nous le lien n'existe absolument pas
entre l'établissement de la filiation et
l'accès aux origines
alors madame picard n'a souhaité
s'exprimer aussi oui moi je vois dans
l'intérêt de la question de monsieur
rapporteur un questionnement
effectivement sur l'intérêt des enfants
de pouvoir et des familles d'ailleurs de
pouvoir être accompagnés et je pense
qu'effectivement c'est ça l'intérêt de
penser une commission ou un organisme
serait ce le cnaps ou autre chose ça là
dessus je veux dire que j'ai pas la
compétence pour y répondre
en revanche ce que je peux dire c'est
qu'effectivement on sait très bien dans
les familles homoparentales que l'enfant
était content de la manière dont
l'enfant a été conçu et et la quête des
origines ce que vous appelez des
originaux ce que d'aucuns appellent les
origines n'est pas du tout systématique
n'est pas du tout une demande
systématique des enfants et que beaucoup
d'enfants ça parfaitement qu'ils soient
conçus dans des familles hétérosexuelles
ou dans une famille aux pectoraux
parentale ou homoparentales savent
parfaitement comment ils ont été conçus
et ne cherchent pas du tout avoir de
renseignements particuliers sur les
donneurs d'autant plus que cette
question là est en général beaucoup
mieux accompagnés des parents puisque il
n'y a pas de traumatismes en dehors de
la question de l'infertilité par exemple
chez les hétérosexuels
il n'y a pas de traumatismes dans la vie
qui est à l'origine de la situation de
l'enfant c'est pas comme un enfant qui
est abandonnée et sur qui pèse comme ça
des questions sur ce qui avait pu
arriver pour que ses enfants ses parents
de naissance un jour soit 1
à l'abandonner et ensuite ils soient
recueillies par une autre famille et là
il ya souvent une question alors que
dans le processus de paix m à il n'y a
pas du tout de situations traumatisantes
bon à part effectivement le peut-être
glam la difficulté notamment chez
certaines personnes hétérosexuelles
d'avoir à surmonter la question
d'infertilité de devoir la surmonter
comme ça et d'accepter même le principe
de la main avec don mais sinon l'enfant
est en général informé de sa conception
et n'a pas de questions particulières
sur le sur le donneur est en revanche ce
qui est important c'est que si par
contre il en a ils soient soulagées de
ces questions là et que ça ne pèse pas
sur lui comme un comme un vrai fardeau
et du coup qu'ils aient la possibilité
de répondre à ces questions est ce que
c'est un allant jusqu'à des rencontres
et c'est bon ça c'est après l'histoire
de d'individus et 2 alors en allant
jusqu'à des rangs oui c'est d'ailleurs
ce que nous a expliqué le cna up dans
les situations qu'ils rencontrent
lui-même dans l'accompagnement des
jeunes qui sont pupille de l'état par
exemple enfin né sous le secret donc oui
effectivement certains ont besoin d'un
accompagnement psychologique et voir
plus et d'être accompagné dans ses
moments de voilà deux rencontres
particulières oui et ça c'est ce que
c'est pour ça que j'ai insisté sur la
différence entre les situations
d'adoption et les situations de dons moi
même je suis psychiatre j'ai vu ensuite
plusieurs fois des personnes qui étaient
dans des situations de rencontrer des
parents les ayant abandonné et je peux
vous dire que ces situations ont été
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que je les
retrouve et moi dans mon parcours de
psychiatres extrêmement traumatisantes
voir le vrai catalyseur vers des moments
de folie pure
donc il faut être très attentif à ça et
c'est pourquoi nous notre position sur
une position d'accompagnement quelles
que soient les situations dans l'intérêt
des familles et dans l'intérêt des
enfants
il n'y a aucune stigmatisation à m il
n'y a aucune
aucun forçage à faire on n'a pas à
imposer sur l'état civil d'un enfant
quelque chose qui concerne l'autre chose
mais l'état dans notre conception doit
être bienveillants à l'égard des
personnes d'autant plus s'il met en
place lui-même un processus
de pma et d'ouverture de la pma il doit
avoir à l'esprit le process
d'accompagnement à l'égard de sa famille
et de ses enfants dans l'intérêt des
familles et dans l'intérêt des enfants
et en effet l'expérience du cnaps peut
nous permettre de penser la manière dont
peuvent être accompagnés des gens
sachant encore une fois que la situation
des personnes adoptées n'est pas la même
même si tous les tous les enfants
adoptés sont pas des enfants traumatisés
par ailleurs il y en a énormément qui se
porte très bien et qui n'ont même pas
cette demande ou alors qu'il supporte
très bien de ne pas pouvoir répondre à
cette question là je vous remercie pour
ces précisions
est ce qu'il y à d'autres demandes oui
de la part de madame meunier la
présidente merci à chacune et à chacun
on sent bien là qu'il ya un point un
point dur en tout cas des pas des
oppositions forcément mais en tout cas
des indices en sus sur cet aspect et je
voulais vous avez été plusieurs à parler
de la mer qui accouche
je voulais vous demander si c'était une
inscription qui était portée état civil
de l'enfant est ce que ça changerait
quelque chose est-ce que ça dans un
souci de transparence ça aiderait au
contraire cela stigmatiserait la mer qui
accouche
est ce que si on le lin skrivet à l'état
civil
ce serait un élément favorable à la fois
de clarification et transparence
d'intérêt pour l'enfant de ce que je
comprends votre question je passe sur
devra complètement saisir les nuances
mais est ce que c'est un point que vous
envisagez pour l'ensemble de la
population ou pour uniquement pour les
pour les femmes 1
qu'homosexuel est-ce que c'est toute la
question si vous voulez la question
quand on demande d'entrer dans le droit
commun c'est pas forcément de de récuser
un certain nombre de positions c'est que
de récuser le fait de devoir porter seul
un point de droit qui est uniquement
liée à l'orientation sexuelle est alors
que ça n'a rien à faire là voilà alors
si toutes les femmes sûr si on révise le
droit de la filiation et qu'on considère
qu'il est important que soient notés sur
l'acte de naissance des enfants que un
moment d'ailleurs c'est un grand
français la mère qui a accouché de vie
c'est pas resté longtemps devait aller
reconnaître son enfant mais c'était le
cas pour toutes les femmes toutes les
femmes devait se déclarer au delà de
l'accouchement
engagé dans le souhait de d'établir la
filiation et de devenir de fait la mère
de l'enfant
bon si c'est le cas pour toutes les
mères parfait mais c'est réservé aux
femmes homosexuelles c'est une
discrimination parce qu'on puisse la
nasa n'a rien à faire là et on ne voit
pas pourquoi ce serait réservé alors
qu'il n'y a rien à voir avec
l'orientation sexuelle ce sera réservé
aux femmes en raison de l'orientation
sexuelle
voilà donc oui c'est vraiment un point
pour nous de discrimination réel je
donne la parole maintenant madame
chainel mais alors j'ai interprété la
question un petit peu différemment
c'était pour moi la question était de 6
en effet comme non droit commun la mer
une des mères devenait par accouchement
qu'en serait-il par rapport à l'autre
mais la question est en fait dont on
il n'y a pas de mystère dans les coupes
on s'est quand même qui est la mère qui
est qui accouchent et l'enfant le sait
qu'il a portés surtout si elles
allaitent après mais après cette mention
elle ouvre un certain nombre de droits
l'accouchement ou un certain nombre de
droits sociaux on parle actuellement de
la réforme des retraites
le fait d'avoir porté des enfants vous
donne actuellement deux années par
enfant peut-être plus tard 5 % de points
il ya la question du droit international
privé selon laquelle le statut de
l'enfant est liée à la mer en tant que
mère qui a accouché
que va-t-il se passer à ce moment là
s'il n'ya plus de distinction entre les
deux et après enfin en tout cas pour
nous les coupes qu'on a consiste le
consulter au sein de l'inter ou au sein
des enfants d'arc en ciel
comme elles ne se sentent pas moins
maire d'avoir accouché ou pas comme
maman par adoption se sent pas moins
maman le fait qu'ils aient une
différence ne les gêne pas puisque ça ne
reflète que le la réalité des choses et
permet aux enfants d'avoir la trace de
ce qui s'est passé je voulais peut-être
d'écouler 1
[Musique]
l'argument aussi sur sur un autre aspect
notamment donc sur sur le fait qu'on sur
la simultanéité de de l'établissement de
la filiation entre les deux mers ce qui
nous a toujours porté c'est
effectivement qu'il y ait égalité en
droits entre les deux parents et donc là
entre les deux maires ça ne souhaitant
pas que la mère qui accouchent que
l'accouchement soit effacée donc à ce
moment là il n'a jamais été question par
exemple dans une famille avec deux
parents hétérosexuels d'effacer
l'accouchement pour que le père soit
égale enfin souhaité également en droit
ont versé ses droits et ses devoirs
envers cet enfant
donc voilà je j'entends souvent là la
confusion pour dire mais il faut traiter
les deux maires à égalité oui certes en
droits parentaux comme un homme et une
femme
enfant dans un couple hétérosexuel
leçons ça ne nécessite pas effectivement
de changer le droit de la filiation pour
une femme qui accouche
quant à sa mention effectivement mais
après ça ça ouvre d'autres portes que a
évoqué sur vic
oui merci merci pour votre question
madame la sénatrice
je rappelle en préalable que toutes les
mentions relatives à des reconnaissances
sont portés systématiquement en marge de
l'acte intégral naissance des personnes
sur la proposition qui a été voté de
reconnaissance conjointe anticipées je
vous renvoie à notre dias d'amendements
et l'amendement numéro 11 qu'on propose
qui est précisément et pour répondre
donc à votre question de rappeler que
l'établissement de la filiation de la
mère qui a accouché est subordonnée au
cumul de deux modalités
la première modalités c'est précisément
de transmettre le certificat
d'accouchement qui indique qu'elle a
accouché et la deuxième modalités c'est
la signature dans la connaissance
conjointe anticipées donc on a bien une
égalité de droit dans l'établissement de
la meuse delà de la filiation puisque
encore une fois il faut obligatoirement
produire la reconnaissance conjointe
anticipées on ne renie à aucun moment la
femme qui accouche et la ministre est
même allé plus loin on n'est absolument
pas opposé à sa elle a proposé que la
femme qui accouche et soit nommé en
premier dans dans l'acte de naissance là
dessus ça peut être une liberté auquel
encore une fois si vous sénateurs
proposent est confirmée le dispositif
que la ministre
à louvain a indiqué ça peut être
effectivement une voix ça peut être
aussi fait par décret un pas besoin
d'une loi sur sur sur ce dispositif
mais la rca ce n'est pas la négation de
la femme qui accouche et au contraire
c'est bien le cumul des deux dispositifs
produire la série d'accouchement et la
reconnaissance conjointe anticipé qui
fait que je suis maire et qui fait que
mon épouse et mère dans le cas d'un
couple lesbien
alors vous souhaitiez compléter madame
chainel je suis désolé j'ai oublié je
pense qu'il ya quelques l'intérêt le
progrès qu'on a eue de faire passer
cette filiation leur accouchement
puisque avant c'était ont été les femmes
non mariées qui devait reconnaître leurs
enfants et on a une une réforme qui une
dizaine d'années qui nous a permis aux
anglais
c'est qu'en fait ça évite aussi que les
enfants se retrouvent par accident sans
état civil parce que comme l'affiliation
est automatique
du coup tous les enfants un état civil à
la naissance au moins enfin ils ont au
moins une filiation établie contre voilà
et la deuxième chose c'est quelque chose
au niveau de l'histoire des lesbiennes
ses terres que les lesbiennes pendant
longtemps ont été discriminés et souvent
considérés comme n'ayant pas vraiment de
sexualité pas de corps pas il ya un
stéréotype assez fort et le fait de ne
pas reconnaître qu'on porte un enfant
comme les autres femmes peut être gênant
pour cette fin vous êtes à interpréter
comme une atteinte à notre féminité
alors je la parole peut-être à vous
souhaitiez compléter celle juste juste
pour compléter pourquoi si tu t'y une
femme homosexuelle
à part un recours à une pma alors
qu'elle est célibataire
alors elle n'aura pas de mention
particulière elle sera considérée comme
un des autres femmes et celle qui aura
une mention particulière le sera en
raison de sa situation de couple avec
une autre femme jeune et on crée
vraiment une situation à regarder le
droit par le bout de la lorgnette
le petit bout de la lorgnette qui nous
paraît incompréhensible et qui porte en
revanche un certain nombre de 2,2
d'idées alors deux discriminations real
et d'idées effectivement extrêmement
préjudiciable je vous remercie et je
vais passer la parole maintenant à
monsieur il daudigny merci à la
présidente je vais revenir sur un sujet
qui est évoqué rapidement qui est la pmr
post mortem
donc on va par développer les arguments
en faveur ou ou défavorable qui sont
bien
bien connue la loi ne le prévoit pas
alors l'information donc en france en
2016 une veuve a été autorisée à
importer d'espagne le sperme de son mari
décédé pour concevoir un enfant donc en
france à la formation est ce qu'elle est
bien exact
est ce que ça ne constitue pas une sorte
de jurisprudence merci pour cette
question que j'aurai finalement posé si
tu ne l'avais pas poser c'est non mais
c'est c'est intéressant aussi d'avoir
l'ensemble de vos avis parce que je
crois qu'il ya un d'entre vous qui a
parlé de cette question mais sans
développer vraiment alors qu'ils
souhaitent prendre la parole madame
chainel c'est moi qu'on ait parlé alors
j'avoue que je n'ai pas cette décision
là quelque part elle ne m'étonne pas
parce que ce qui est intéressant dans la
pma pouces mortem c'est que toutes les
institutions concernées enfin consulter
que ce soit le cc ne le conseille pas
tout le monde y est plutôt favorable en
fait
ça paraît assez logique donc une qu'une
juridiction est pris cette décision
savard et bien après attention parce que
notamment dans le projet de loi il ya
des évolutions sur le transfert éventuel
des gamètes et encore une fois fin
pourquoi si en plus on l'autorisent de
l'étranger pourquoi obliger les gens à
aller faire une démarche à l'étranger ou
payantes stressante pour une démarche
qui pourrait faire en france
alors madame jourda souhaite à nouveau
poser une question que tel nous ont bien
que je ne sois pas auditionner je
précise que dans cette décision la femme
était espagnole et est retournée voilà
elle est retournée quand même dans son
pays d'origine où la pma post mortem et
est autorisé on ne l'obligeait pas à
partir ailleurs en fait c'était de son
propre chef parce que c'était son pays
d'origine
merci pour cette précision
vous ne souhaitez pas intervenir sur la
pma post mortem
je veux dire que c'est pas du tout notre
sujet fait un autre débat de en tant
qu'association mais simplement je peux
témoigner de ce que les associations
avec lesquelles nous travaillons parce
que nous faisons partie d'un collectif
qui regroupe de nombreuses associations
et y compris des associations par
exemple de mamans solos ou de du
planning familial ou d'associations
comme collectif banques sont favorables
1 et qui sont davantage concernés que
nous bien sûr sont favorables à sa
couverture de la pma passe martin je
vous remercie est-ce que vous souhaitiez
apporter quelques précisions sur
d'autres sujets que nous n'aurions pas
abordés madame regarde oui je je je
tiens à dire que j'ai déjà dit tout à
l'heure mais je le redis pour ouvrir un
autre un autre volet nous nous
souhaiterions que ce débat qui va qui
pose la question là on est d'ailleurs en
train de tourner dessus depuis tout à
l'heure de la filiation de ne devrait
pas être une occasion manquée pour
l'ensemble des situations familiales
le projet de loi est intéressant en ce
qu'il pleut ils rêvent il valait 2
points
la nécessité d'ouvrir la filiation hors
mariage pour les couples de femmes et
deuxièmement eu un instant et
deuxièmement de sécuriser les liens
familiaux alors on ne sommes pas
d'accord avec les modalités proposées
mais sur le principe nous sommes
absolument d'accord avec la nécessité un
qui est apparu à tous de sécuriser les
liens familiaux de la naissance de
l'enfant
c'est à dire de sortir du de ce qui nous
avait été donné en héritage par la loi
mariage qu'ils ne reconnaissaient la
famille homoparentale que dans le cadre
du mariage et de l'adoption
intrafamiliales avec tous les écueils
que ça pouvait supposer notamment pour
les familles qui sont séparés notamment
pour les gens qui ne veulent pas se
marier
voilà et notamment pour les pma qui
seront réalisés à l'étranger
donc il est extrêmement important pour
nous que le droit soit pensée de manière
homogène et permettent à ces situations
familiales différentes d'être sécurisée
dans le droit qui sera proposé c'est
aussi pour ça que l'entrée dans le droit
commun est extrêmement importante parce
que si il est possible de reconnaître un
enfant en validant un processus de pma
et ça le législateur devrait pouvoir y
pensez y compris un processus de paix
est mac qui s'est déroulé à l'étranger
ou qui s'est déroulé il ya plusieurs
années dans la mesure où les
participants peuvent valider ensemble et
conjointement le principe de la double
filiation et bien ça résoudrait tout un
tas de situations qui aujourd'hui sont
simplement des sources de souffrance
infinie pour des gens qui ont été
séparés avant la loi pour des enfants
qui n'ont pas pu reconnaître la deuxième
filiation pour des pma qui demain seront
faites à l'étranger et du coup si on
pense la filiation penser à a donné
quelques outils supplémentaires qui
pourraient tout à fait être valide dans
le cadre de la reconnaissance des
familles homoparentales et des coupes de
femmes en particulier dans le cadre là
qui va s'ouvrir à elle on permettant
d'établir une filiation par la
possession d'état ou en eau en modifiant
quand même le process de l'adoption
intrafamiliales
je sais qu'il ya une une commission de
réflexion sur la réforme de l'adoption
qui nous paraît un espoir quand même
pour bon nombre de situations c'est
indispensable mais mais tous ces points
là doivent être pris en compte de
manière urgente
parce que en 2013 on nous a promis qu'on
nous a voté le mariage et l'adoption
intrafamiliales en nous promettant des
réformes dans la filiation de réforme du
droit de la famille etc
elle résout tout un tas de situations on
nous a vendus voilà des promesses qui
n'ont qui n'ont pas été tenues pour
différentes raisons
aujourd'hui le débat politique est
beaucoup plus apaisé il me semble qu'il
est il est indispensable que on a vu que
le mariage ne ne crée pas de drame à
l'intérieur des familles ni de la
société bien au contraire il a permis
l'intégration de familles et d'enfants
de manière extrêmement favorable et du
coup c'est le moment me semble-t-il de
penser dans ce cadre qui s'ouvre qui est
une réflexion sur la filiation d'élargir
davantage et de ne pas se cantonner à
même ce débat de que nous venons d'avoir
sur les questions de de l'établissement
de la filiation et garde la mer qui
accouchent et de sa compagne mais de
penser de faire entrer du même coup dans
le dans le droit commun justement la
possibilité de deux d'établissement en
mariage de filiation leur mariage voilà
et c'est donc je pense qu'il ya vraiment
là un cochonnet
à ne pas rater et ne pas s'en remettre à
plus tard et nous demander d'attendre
encore pour que ces droits puisse
advenir
je vous remercie madame est ce que vous
souhaitiez ajouter quelques ce monsieur
fait bien jolie oui très rapidement un
mail présidente
je crois qu'on est tous d'accord en tout
cas toutes les associations ici sont
d'accord pour penser un système qui
puisse être le plus protecteur aussi
bien pour l'enfant qui est n'est que
pour les les femmes ou les hommes qui en
sont les parents après nous divergeons
effectivement sur les modalités et le
choix que le législateur retiendra comme
le disait alexandre vi nous sommes nous
pour la rca vous l'avez bien compris et
nous sommes pour la rca est tendu donc
aux couples hétérosexuels mais aussi
aux femmes célibataires pour et là on
raisonne uniquement dans une optique de
sécurisation de leurs propres droits à l
ac femme célibataire parce
qu'aujourd'hui
et bien si la rca et été étendue aussi
aux femmes célibataires
ça permettrait de prémunir ces femmes là
de toute reconnaissance indus venant
notamment d'un homme qui pourrait comme
vous le savez à tout moment déclaré sa
paternité à l'égard d'un enfant qui ne
pourraient pas auquel il ne pourrait pas
être j'ai dit icm publié puisqu'ils y
lire l'enfant serait né d'un don de
sperme avec la rca et bien puisqu'elles
seraient mentionnées sur l'acte de
naissance la reconnaissance serait alors
paternel serait impossible puisque
l'officier d'état civil saurait qu'il y
a eu une herse et à verser à keane a
induit l'établissement d'une seule
filiation à l'égard de la femme qui a
accouché donc qui empêcherait que une
reconnaissance paternelle puisse
intervenir
après si cette femme l'a fait sa vie
avec un homme ou une femme et que cet
homme ou cette femme ce conjoint veut
adopter l'enfant évidemment ce serait
toujours possible mais là on serait dans
une dans un système adoptif ou le lien
de filiation laissé vacant et bien
pourrait être suppléé du fait d'une
adoption
mais il ya cet élément-là la rca ne
concerne pas que les couples
elle concerne aussi les femmes
célibataires qui leur permet c'était un
projet parental qu'elles ont porté seul
je crois qu'on l'a dit et là on rejoint
c'est un projet parental qui est
réfléchie et mûrie 1
on ne fait pas du tout je crois que
c'est madame chainel qui le disaient on
ne fait pas un enfant quand on est
célibataire à vialas pma comme on le
fait lorsqu'on a été en couple et puis
que le père s'en va les situations sont
radicalement différentes
mais puisqu'on le sait est un projet
parental comporte seul il faut alors
être sûr que bien la filiation sera
garantie à l'égard de l'a72 cette seule
femme et qu'il n'y a pas eu notre
filiation qui pourrait être indûment et
irrégulièrement établi par la suite
voilà à et et puis un dernier point il y
avait la mine madame la ministre la
justice avait devant l'assemblée
nationale
affirmer que les pma qui serait fait
qu'ils continueraient à être faites à
l'étranger
après l'entrée en vigueur de la loi et
bien pourrait bénéficier de l'ars cole
la reconnaissance conjointe anticipées
j'avoue que j'avais eu quelque peu de
difficulté à comprendre comment ça
pourrait se passer
interrogée la direction civile a fait à
des affaires civiles et du sceau pardon
nous a indiqué qu'en réalité il
suffirait que ces femmes puissent
finalement signer leurs consentements
devant notaire et la rca avant qu'il y
ait l'insémination fait à l'étranger et
qu'ensuite lorsqu elle accouchera en
france eh bien elle
elle pourrait produire comme n'importe
quelle femme qui aurait pu cette fois ci
a qu'à voir connaître une assimilation
fait dans le cadre médical français
elle pourrait présenter cet versée à et
l'établissement de la filiation serait
alors établi de la même manière que pour
les femmes qui auraient fait l'entièreté
du processus médical en france
donc voilà je tenais à apporter cette
information si vous ne l'aviez pas votre
connaissance parce que pour moi
l'affirmation de la ministre était resté
un peu sèche et je ne comprenais pas
puisqu'il ya pas de dispositions
particulières dans le texte de loi
comment on allait organiser ça la
direction des affaires civiles et du
sceau semble nous avoir en tout cas
rassuré sur ce point là voilà très
rapidement et juste pour un tout petit
et conclusif changement de focale et je
crois que l'on on se retrouvera tous de
tous deux côtés de cette assemblée
donc pour simplement souligner à nouveau
le lien documenté et réels qui existe
entre discrimination inscrite dans le
droit ou dans les procédures de droit ou
dans les jurisprudences puisque d'autres
pays notamment anglo saxons travaille
plus sur la jurisprudence et les
discriminations réel subi par les
personnes discriminées endroit il y a un
lien réel dans tout ce que nous tous les
parlementaires et les législateurs que
vous êtes pourront inscrire dans la loi
ne pas inscrire dans la loi ont des
conséquences très réel pour les
personnes concernées dans la vie et nous
chez sos homophobie donc avec ce rapport
annuel que nous publions donc tous les
ans nous sommes bien placés pour pour le
savoir d'où notre attention extrême à un
traitement d'égalité
d'autant plus quand les situations sont
évidemment égal et je rejoins encore une
fois les propos de claude picarda sur la
non nécessité
voir une différence là où elle n'a pas
lieu d'être merci merci je voulais juste
apporte une précision à ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure des femmes des mères
seules se sont organisés en associations
et les mamans solos
elles portent leurs paroles elles sont
contre l'inscription à l'état civil de
la rca et donc je pense qu'il est
inutile de parler à leur place d'autant
plus que je crois vous les avez
auditionné vous voulez conclut
relationnel oui puisqu'on termine la
conclusion par l'ouverture donc juste
pour un sujet un peu différent dont on a
peu parlé mais qui est un vrai souci sur
l'intérêt que gvt c'est sur le
traitement des données de santé
c'est un souci qu'on a déjà porté dans
le cas de la loi de révision du système
de santé et des garanties données aux
personnes sur l'utilisation sur le
respect de leur consentement comme
devrait l'imposé les conséquences de la
loi kouchner et de la loi informatique
et libertés c'est un enjeu particulier
pour nous parce que notamment les
questions d'orientation sexuelle mais
après les questions de séropositivité
par exemple ont des coûts s'il ya des
fuites on peut avoir des conséquences
dramatiques en termes d'assurance de vie
et même de prise en charge de refus de
discrimination de prise en charge
médicale et du coup le on pense aussi
qu'il faut absolument qu'ils un
dispositif d' alerte donnée à la has
pour que quand il y ait des soucis de
transparence sur l'utilisation des
données de santé on puisse tout de suite
avoir une réaction c'est bien de donner
une mission il faut concrètement la
donner à une institution pour que ce
droit soit effectif je vous remercie
alors messieurs oui merci donc pour
conclure et aussi pour rebondir
finalement sur l'aspect médical qui a
été évoqué par lauren cheney
c'est vrai qu'on a énormément focaliser
débat sur sur la rca mais pardon
l'aspect médical est aussi très
important est ce que vous voulez vous
sénateurs créer une rupture d'égalité
je vais utiliser le mot de chances de
survie des enfants conçus par don
alors que certains auraient
l'information qu'ils ont été conçus par
d'autres leur famille leur a transmis et
d'autres non à l'heure de la médecine
prédictive
à l'heure où on doit vérifier le
patrimoine génétique du donneur pour
savoir si une maladie potentiellement
non détectables en 2019 le qu'il serait
en 2021 aura une incidence sur sa vie et
sur la vie de ses descendants est-ce
qu'on veut maintenir ce secret ou est ce
qu'on veut au contraire ouvrir et mettre
à disposition ce droit je rappelle que
c'est un droit un droit n'est pas une
obligation si on veut aller ouvrir cette
porte qui mène à l'accès aux histoires
personnelles on peut le faire si on veut
ne pas l'ouvrir
eh bien on n'ouvre pas mais au moins
connaître l'existence de cette porte
c'est avoir été mis en responsabilité
quand on est législateur charge ensuite
à cette famille
effectivement de l'ouvrir ou 7 ans vont
l'ouvrir encore une fois sur l'accès aux
informations médicales et les
conséquences que cela peut avoir sur la
vie des enfants conçus par don mettons
tous ces enfants à égalité le sénat a
donc entendu les associations de
familles homoparentales sur ce projet de
loi de bioéthique qui ouvre la
procréation médicalement assistée aux
couples lesbiens ces associations sont
globalement satisfaites de cette avancée
sociétale mais elles ont un motif de
mécontentement le gouvernement veut
distinguer dans la loi la filiation des
couples lesbiens et la filiation qui
existe déjà pour les couples
hétérosexuels
les familles homoparentales estime que
c'est une discrimination et veulent une
seule filiation quel que soit le type de
famille
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain rendez vous de
l'actualité parlementaire et politique à
18h30 pour allons plus loin avec rebecca
fitoussi
ce sera une émission notamment consacré
aux négociations sur la réforme des
retraites très bonne soirée sur public
sénat
[Musique]